Hey there, before we start today's episode, I wanted to share something I'm really excited about. Hidden Brain is now on YouTube. We just dropped an episode exploring a strategy that can help us to solve problems and save time, but it's a strategy almost all of us overlook. I hope you'll check it out. You can find us at YouTube.com slash at Hidden Brain, or just follow the link in today's show notes. Okay, here's today's show.
大家好，在今天的节目开始前，我想分享一件让我非常兴奋的事。Hidden Brain 现已开通 YouTube 频道。我们刚刚发布了一期节目，探讨了一种能帮助我们解决问题并节省时间的策略，但这却是一种几乎所有人都会忽视的策略。希望大家能去看看。你可以在 YouTube.com 搜索 @Hidden Brain，或者直接点击今天节目简介中的链接。好了，今天的节目马上开始。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. In Shakespeare's play, The Merchant of Venice, Portia is a beautiful, wealthy woman, and she is looking for the right man to marry. Her father has decreed that a successful suitor must pass a test. Each of Portia's admirers is presented with three caskets, made of gold, silver, and lead. Portia's portrait is inside one. Suiters have to pick the right casket. The gold casket is inscribed with the words,
这里是 Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在莎士比亚的戏剧《威尼斯商人》中，鲍西亚是一位美丽而富有的小姐，她正在寻找合适的结婚对象。她的父亲规定，成功的追求者必须通过一项考验。鲍西亚的每一位追求者面前都会出现三个匣子，分别由黄金、铅和银制成。鲍西亚的肖像就藏其中一个匣子里。追求者必须挑出正确的匣子。金匣子上刻着这样的话：
Who Chuseth Me shall gain what many men desire. The Prince of Morocco selects it and discovers it's the wrong choice. On the silver casket are the words, Who Chuseth Me shall get as much as he deserves. The Prince of Aragon opts for this casket. He too loses out. Finally, the noble Bessaniol takes a turn. He picks the lead casket, which bears the sobering warning,
选择我的人，将得到众人所愿。摩洛哥亲王选择了它，却发现选错了。银匣子上写着：选择我的人，将得到他应得的一切。阿拉贡亲王选择了这个匣子。他也失败了。最后，贵族巴萨尼奥登场了。他选择了铅匣子，上面带着一个令人清醒的警告：
Who chooses me, must give and hazard all he hath. It turns out to be the right choice. Having picked correctly, Bessano gets to marry Portia. In Shakespeare's time, tests like these may have seemed odd, but charming. But if you set up tests of devotion like this today, it would strike your suitors as puzzling, even preposterous. But that doesn't mean many of us don't devise our own tests of love. We hold off texting someone we met, hoping they will reach out first.
选择我的人，必须付出并押上他所拥有的一切。事实证明，这是正确的选择。挑对之后的巴萨尼奥得以迎娶鲍西亚。在莎士比亚的时代，这样的考验或许显得古怪却颇具魅力。但如果你今天设立这样的忠诚考验，你的追求者会觉得莫名其妙，甚至是荒谬。但这并不意味着我们当中许多人不会设计自己对爱的考验。我们会忍着不给刚认识的人发信息，希望对方能先联系我们。
We drop hints about what we want for a birthday present to see if our partner notices. We act distant in the hope it will prompt another person to come closer. Just like the tests in the Merchant of Venice, our tests of love can easily be seen as manipulation. If finding love is about connection and intimacy, tests create distance, and suspicion. What is the hunger inside us that drives us to test the devotion of others? What are we really looking for when we hope our partner selects the ideal anniversary gift? What do we really want when we dream of the perfect proposal? New psychological research suggests that many of us do not really understand our own needs.
我们会暗示自己想要什么生日礼物，以此看看伴侣有没有注意到。我们会表现得冷漠，希望借此促使另一个人向我们靠近。就像《威尼斯商人》中的考验一样，我们对爱的考验也很容易被看作是一种操纵。如果寻找真爱关乎连接与亲密，那么考验带来的则是距离与猜疑。究竟是我们内心的什么饥饿感，驱使着去考验别人的忠诚？当我们希望伴侣挑选出理想的周年纪念礼物时，我们真正寻找的究竟是什么？当我们梦想着完美的求婚时，我们内心真正渴望的又是什么？新的心理学研究表明，我们许多人其实并不真正了解自己的需求。
How surprising can it be that we reach for the wrong strategies? What we truly want from our intimate relationships and how to get it, This week on Hidden Brain. We all want to be loved. It's one of our deepest longings, a need so fundamental that we are willing to twist ourselves in knots to satisfy it. Yet psychologists say that many of the strategies we rely on to obtain love are either ineffective or counterproductive.
我们追求错误的策略，这又有什么好奇怪的呢？我们从亲密关系中真正想要的是什么，以及如何去获得它，本周的 Hidden Brain。我们都渴望被爱。这是我们最深层的渴望之一，是一种如此基础的需求，以至于我们愿意把自己扭曲成各种形状去满足它。然而心理学家表示，我们用来获得爱的许多策略要么毫无效果，要么适得其反。
Instead of bringing us closer to the warmth we seek, we often end up pushing it away. At the University of California, Riverside, psychologist Sonia Lubomirsky studies what we do to feel loved and what we ought to be doing. Sonia Lubomirsky, welcome to Hidden Brain. Such a pleasure to be here. Sonia, you're a fan of the TV program Couples Therapy. I haven't watched the show.
非但没有让我们离所追求的温暖更近，我们往往反倒将其推开。在加州大学河滨分校，心理学家索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基研究着我们为感受爱而做的事情，以及我们本该去做的事情。索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基，欢迎来到 Hidden Brain。很高兴来到这里。索尼娅，你是电视节目《夫妻治疗》的粉丝。我没看过这个节目。
Can you describe it for me and tell me about some of the patterns you've noticed? Such a great show, right? So these are real couples in New York. They kind of forget that they're on camera, and they have major problems. They're all very diverse. And I just feel like over the years, so much resentment and so much disappointment has built up. It's very hard for me. And what I love about the show, it actually makes me feel very smart because you hear them talking.
你能为我描述一下它，并讲讲你注意到的一些模式吗？真是个极好的节目，对吧？这里面是纽约的真实夫妻。他们有点忘了自己在镜头前，他们有着重大问题。他们背景各异。我只是觉得多年来，太多的怨恨和失望积聚起来了。这对我来说很难。而我喜欢这个节目的一点是，它其实让我觉得自己很聪明，因为你听着他们的对话。
And it's like the wife is saying, oh, you never bring me to the gym. You don't do this. You don't do this. Or the husband's saying, oh, you haven't done this for me. And then you see, like, they're fighting, fighting over here on this level. But really underneath it, it seems so obvious that. they don't feel loved. That, like, no matter what the guy does, she still doesn't feel love.
就像妻子在说，哦，你从不带我去健身房。你根本不这么做。你从来不这样。或者丈夫在说，哦，你从来没为我做过这个。然后你会看到，他们就在这里这个层面上争吵不休。但实际上在这一切背后，显而易见的是。他们感觉不到被爱。就像，无论那家伙做什么，她还是感觉不到爱。
No matter what she does, he doesn't feel loved. But I really feel like at the heart of a lot of problems in relationships or even breakups, it's a lack of feeling love. No matter what the other person does, you still don't feel loved by them. I understand, Sonia, that you've recently separated, and not long ago you went on a date with a man who tried to win your affections. I understand he spoke a lot about his car. It was really funny. So he had just bought this really brand new high end, like the highest end Tesla.
无论她做什么，他都感觉不到爱。但我真的觉得，许多关系问题的核心，甚至是分手的核心，就是缺乏被爱的感觉。无论对方做什么，你依然感觉不到来自他们的爱。我明白，索尼娅，你最近分居了，不久前你和一个试图赢得你欢心的男士约会了。我听说他谈了很多关于他车子的事。这真的太逗了。他刚买了一辆全新的高端特斯拉，可以说是最高端的车型。
And so the whole ride to the restaurant we're going to, he was showing off the car. And it was actually really cool. Like he's showing off all these features of the Tesla. It was like all the self-driving stuff and like really cool, cool features that I had not seen before. And I enjoyed it. And at the end of the drive, I said, you know, I'll just call him Patrick, not his real name. I said, I said, He said, Patrick, you've persuaded me. I'm going to date your Tesla. Like, I'm impressed. And he's a funny guy. He actually said, well, you know, in a few years, you probably can.
所以在去我们目的地的整个车程中，他都在炫耀那辆车。其实真的挺酷的。就像他在展示特斯拉的各种功能。全都是自动驾驶之类的，还有我以前没见过的超级酷炫的功能。我很享受。在车程结束时，我说，你知道的，我就叫他帕特里克吧，这不是他的真名。我说，我说，他说，帕特里克，你成功说服我了。我要和你的特斯拉约会。我的意思是，我被打动了。他是个有趣的人。他居然说，好吧，你知道的，过几年你大概真的可以。
But he was trying to impress me the whole time with how great his car was. And did you think he noticed that he was doing so? Do you think he was doing so consciously, deliberately? Had he given some thought to this? You know, maybe after thinking about it, he might have been aware of it. but he's a smart guy. I feel like he should have been aware of it. But I feel like it's so human. It's part of our human nature to want to impress others, right? It's evolutionarily adaptive for us to impress a new potential date or a new business partner or a new friend. And so when we talk to
但他一直在试图用他的车有多棒来给我留下深刻印象。你觉得他意识到自己这么做了吗？你觉得他是刻意、故意这么做的吗？他在这方面动过脑筋吗？你知道的，也许事后想起来，他可能会意识到这一点。但他是个聪明人。我觉得他本该意识到这一点的。但我感觉这是太人性化了。渴望给他人留下好印象是我们人性的一部分，对吧？向新的潜在约会对象、新的商业伙伴或新朋友展示自己，这在进化上对我们是有适应意义的。所以当我们交谈时，
each other, especially towards the beginning of relationships, we want the other person to think that we're kind and interesting and intelligent and funny. And we might succeed in impressing the other person. But what it doesn't do is it doesn't really forge a connection, right? So you don't really leave that interaction feeling like, ah, I really am connected with that person. I understand that another day turned into a full-fledged relationship, but this one had something of a fatal flaw. Tell me what happened. I had a relationship with someone who really did love me, who I knew loved me, but I actually broke it off. And it's going to sound almost crazy about what the main reason was that I broke it off. And the main reason was,
尤其是在关系刚开始的时候，我们希望对方觉得我们善良、有趣、聪明、幽默。我们可能确实成功给对方留下了深刻印象。但这么做并不能真正建立连接，对吧？所以你离开那次互动时，并不会觉得，啊，我和那个人真的建立起了连接。我听说另一段约会发展成了正式的关系，但这段关系却有一个致命的缺陷。告诉我发生了什么。我和一个真正爱我的人谈过恋爱，我也知道他爱我，但我实际上主动提出了分手。我分手的最主要原因听起来可能会让人觉得有点疯狂。最主要的理由是，
he just didn't text me like often enough or kind of speedily enough. You know, he took so long to respond to my messages. And, you know, I often think that the texting is like the currency of modern relationships, right? That's what a lot of us are doing in relationships is texting. And I realized later it's just the lack of texting, that lack of responsiveness did not make me feel loved. And that was at the heart of it. What did you hear when he did not text to you, enough, Sonia. What went through your head?
他给我发信息不够频繁，或者说不够迅速。你知道的，他回复我的信息花的时间太久了。而且，我经常觉得发短信就像是现代关系的货币，对吧？我们在关系中做了很多的事情就是发短信。我后来意识到，正是缺乏发短信，这种缺乏响应度让我觉得没有被爱。这才是核心所在。索尼娅，当他没有给你发足够的信息时，你心里是怎么想的？你的脑海里闪过了什么？
It's like, I don't, I don't care enough. Yeah, like the worst, the worst interpretation is like something like, I don't care enough about your feelings. Like, I know you're waiting. And it's like this thing, this idea that you're like, if you really loved me, you would care, you would know how important it is to respond right away and you still are not doing it. And so that's what's going on in my head. Did you have a breakup conversation where you actually took? told him the reason you were breaking up with him?
就像是，我不在乎，我不在乎得还不够。是的，最糟糕的解释就是类似于，我根本不在乎你的感受。就像，我知道你在等。而且这种感觉就是，如果你真的爱我，你在乎的话，你就会知道立刻回复是多么重要，而你却偏偏不这样做。这就是我脑海中在想的事情。你们进行过分手谈话吗？你真的把分手的理由告诉他了吗？
Yes, and we actually have had that texting conversation repeatedly before the breakup. And, you know, and he would apologize, and he would sort of do better for a little while. And he would explain all the ways that he did show love to me, just not through texting. And just in the end, it just wasn't enough. One last story, Sonia. You have four kids, the oldest of whom is in her 20s. You've seen the same patterns we've been discussing when it comes to your relationships with your kids. Can you say more?
是的，在分手之前，我们其实已经进行过很多次关于发短信的对话了。而且，你知道的，他会道歉，然后会有那么一小段时间做得好一点。他会解释他向我表达爱的所有方式，只是不通过发短信而已。但到头来，这还是不够。最后一个问题，索尼娅。你有四个孩子，最大的已经二十多岁了。在处理与孩子们的亲密关系时，你也看到了我们一直在讨论的那些相同模式。能多说一点吗？
So I realized one day that I just wasn't feeling as loved as I wanted to by my adult daughter. She doesn't sort of share that much with me. And I just realized that I just wasn't feeling as loved as I wanted to be. I think it's a fairly common situation. I'm wondering how this perception came about when you felt like you were not being loved by, your oldest daughter. What was she doing specifically that made you feel this way? Or what was she not doing that made you feel this way?
所以我有一天突然意识到，我从大女儿那里感受到的爱，没有达到我想要的程度。她不太愿意跟我分享那么多事情。我只是意识到，我没有感受到自己所期望的那种被爱。我想这是一种相当普遍的情况。我很好奇，当你觉得大女儿没有给你足够的爱时，这种感知是如何产生的？她具体做了什么让你有这种感觉？或者她没有做什么让你觉得这样？
What she was not doing is she wasn't sharing very much about herself. She wasn't showing sort of as much affection, physical affection as much as I like, because I'm a very physical person. So I was sort of focused on what she was not doing enough or thinking, like, what should I be doing to try to get her to be more responsive to me? Kind of what was wrong with me? that I wasn't feeling this love coming from her.
她没有做的是，她不太愿意分享关于她自己的事情。她表现出的温情，也就是身体上的亲密接触，没有达到我喜欢的程度，因为我是一个对肢体接触很敏感的人。所以我当时有点专注于她做得不够的地方，或者在想，我该怎么做才能让她对我的回应更多一点？是不是我身上有什么问题。才导致我没有感受到她对我的爱。
In some ways, it's a variation of what happened with the guy who wasn't texting back quickly enough. It was sort of a lack of responsiveness in some ways that you were perceiving as a lack of love. Yeah, that's exactly right. It's so interesting, you know, because we often don't feel loved for a variety of reasons. And sometimes the person really, really does love us, and they might even show love in different ways, but it somehow isn't registering with. us for a variety of reasons, maybe because that's not, quote, our love language, or maybe because
从某种程度上讲，这和那个回信息不够快的家伙身上的情况如出一辙。从某些方面来看，这是一种缺乏回应的表现，而被你感知为缺乏爱。是的，完全正确。这真的很有趣，你知道的，因为我们常常由于各种原因而感觉不到被爱。有时对方其实真的非常爱我们，他们甚至可能通过不同的方式表达爱，但由于种种原因，不知为何我们就是没有接收到。也许是因为那不是我们所谓的爱的语言，又或者是因为
we don't sort of even see it, or we don't think of it as being very, very authentic, or we don't think it doesn't apply to us. So it's a very interesting problem. Whether it's our children, our friends, or our partners, what we want most from relationships is to feel cared for and appreciated, to feel loved. But achieving this is much harder than it looks. when we come back, how we go about trying to feel loved in all the wrong ways. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
我们根本没有注意到，或者我们不认为那是真诚的，或者我们觉得那不适用于我们。所以这是一个非常有趣的问题。无论是我们的孩子、朋友还是伴侣，我们从关系中最想要的是被关怀和赞赏的感觉，也就是感受被爱。但要做到这一点，比看上去要困难得多。稍后回来，我们将探讨我们如何以完全错误的方式去寻求被爱的感觉。你正在收听的是 Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all want to be loved. We want to feel cared for and appreciated by our friends and by our partners. We want our parents and our kids to tell us how much we mean to them. But many of us walk around with what you might call a love deficit. psychologist Sonia Lubomirski says we don't realize there's a difference between being loved and feeling loved. Sonia, let's start there. I think most of us assume that being loved and feeling loved are the same thing. Aren't they?
这里是 Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们都渴望被爱。我们希望从朋友和伴侣那里感受到关怀和赞赏。我们希望父母和孩子告诉我们，我们在他们心中有多重要。但我们许多人身上都带着一种可以称之为“爱的赤字”的东西。心理学家索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基表示，我们并没有意识到被爱与感受到爱之间存在差异。索尼娅，我们就从这里开始吧。我想我们大多数人都认为被爱和感受到爱是一回事。难道不是吗？
I think often they are. But I think the interesting case, you know, for me as a psychologist, are the times when we are loved but we don't feel loved. And it could be that we're not even seeing what, whatever the other person is doing to make us feel loved, we're not perceiving it, we're not somehow taking it in, we're not internalizing it, that love is it being felt. How common do you think it is, this discrepancy between being loved and feeling loved? Do you think it happens a lot?
我想通常它们是的。但我认为，作为一个心理学家，最有趣的情况是那些我们被爱着，却没有感受到爱的时刻。可能是因为我们甚至没有看到对方为了让我们感受到爱而做的任何事情，我们没有感知到它，不知为何我们没有把它吸收进来，没有将其内化，所以那份爱并没有被切实地感受到。你认为被爱与感受到爱之间的这种不一致有多普遍？你觉得它经常发生吗？
I think it happens a lot. You know, Harry Rees, my co-author and I did a survey where we asked people, are there relationships in your life that you sometimes don't feel as loved as you would like to be, you know, or as frequently as you'd like to be? And something I think, like, 70% said that, yes, there's at least one. one relationship in which I don't feel as loved as I want to be. I actually think that number is an understatement. You know, I actually think it's a lot higher than that. But 70% is a lot, you know, and so maybe it's your colleague, it's your romantic partner, your mom, your child,
我认为这经常发生。你知道的，我的合著者哈里·里斯和我做过一项调查，我们问人们，你的生活中是否存在这样的人际关系：有时你感觉不到自己渴望的那种程度的爱，你知道的，或者达不到你希望的频率？我记得大约有 70% 的人回答说，是的，至少有一段关系中，我没有感受到自己所期望的那么多的爱。我甚至觉得这个数字还是保守的。你知道的，我其实觉得实际比例要高得多。但 70% 已经很多了，你知道的，所以也许是你的同事、你的恋爱伴侣、你的妈妈、你的孩子，
you know, your friend. It's, I think it's very common. People also told you in the survey, this was a large survey with almost 2,000 individuals that they didn't feel loved by their communities. So it wasn't just the intimate relationships in people's lives. It was the larger social settings that they found themselves in. Absolutely. And you know, there's sort of this lack of feeling. You can also call it a lack of feeling of belonging, which I think is very much related to feeling love. Loneliness is very much related. You can argue that being lonely really is basically not feeling loved by your community friends. You know, some people argue this is an epidemic. But this really raises an important point, which is that most people when they think of love,
你知道的，还有你的朋友。我认为这是非常普遍的。人们在调查中还告诉你，这是一项拥有近 2,000 名参与者的大型调查，他们觉得来自社群的爱也有所欠缺。所以这不仅限于人们生活中的亲密关系，还包括他们所处的更广泛的社交环境。绝对是的。你知道的，这种缺乏感受的状态。你也可以称之为缺乏归属感，我认为这与感受爱息息相关。孤独感与此高度相关。你可以说，感到孤独实际上基本上就是没有感受到来自社群朋友的爱。你知道的，有些人认为这是一场流行病。但这确实提出了一个重要观点，那就是大多数人在想到爱时，
they think of romantic love or passionate love. They think of love between romantic partners. But, you know, there's love in the workplace. And by the way, I think the word love is not used often enough at work, you know. I think we should bring it back to the workplace. Love among friends, neighbors. My friends and I often say, I love you to each other. And so people are confused.
他们想到的是浪漫的爱或充满激情的爱。他们想到的是恋爱伴侣之间的爱。但是，你知道的，职场中也有爱。顺便说一句，我认为在工作中“爱”这个词的使用频率还不够高，你知道的。我认为我们应该把爱带回职场。朋友、邻居之间的爱。我和我的朋友们经常对彼此说“我爱你”。所以人们会感到困惑。
Like, I'll be on the phone and I'll say, I love you so much. And I hang up the phone. And my kids are like, who are you talking to? And I'm like, that's my friend. because I love my friends very much. So we define love very broadly. I understand that one of the areas that had the largest gaps between being loved and feeding loved was a romantic relationship.
比如，我正在通电话，然后说我太爱你了。接着我挂了电话。我的孩子们就会问，你刚才在跟谁说话？然后我说，那是我的朋友。因为我非常爱我的朋友。所以我们对爱的定义非常广泛。我了解到，在被爱与感受到爱之间差距最大的领域之一，就是恋爱关系。
So there are lots of people in romantic relationships. These are people who ostensibly are loved because they're in a romantic relationship who feel like they're not. That's exactly right. It is very common to not feel loved. At least, it may be even during a period of time during a romantic relationship.
所以有很多人处于恋爱关系中。这些人表面上是被人爱着的，因为他们正在谈恋爱，但他们自己却觉得并没有。完全正确。感觉不到被爱是非常普遍的。至少，甚至可能是在恋爱关系中的某一段时间里，
and maybe in a particular domain of that relationship, maybe certain activities you do together that you sort of don't feel love by your partner. Maybe when they don't do chores in the house, you don't feel loved by them, or they don't respond to your texts, you don't feel love by them. So I do think it's extremely common.
也许是在该关系的某个特定领域，也许你们一起进行的某些活动让你觉得没有感受到伴侣的爱。也许当他们不做家务时，你感觉不到他们的爱，或者当他们不回你的信息时，你感觉不到他们的爱。所以我确实认为这极其普遍。
You asked respondents to describe moments when they did not feel loved. Can you give me some of the examples that they shared with you, Sonia? Often it's not being invited. Actually, that was a very common one. not being invited to something, sort of not being included to, you know, maybe a social event, not remembering something important to you.
你让受访者描述了他们感觉不到被爱的时刻。索尼娅，你能举几个他们与你分享的例子吗？通常是不被邀请。事实上，这是一个非常普遍的例子。没有被邀请参加某些活动，也就是没有被纳入其中，你知道的，也许是一个社交活动，或者不记得对你来说很重要的事。
You know, I think feeling loved comes, is very highly related to sort of feeling understood. And so when people feel like, I'm not really seen, I'm understood that this person never asked me about, you know, this passion of mine, forgetting a birthday, you know, often it's those kinds of events that really like drive at home, like I don't feel loved. And also when people were suffering or sick, I mean, you really want people to check in on you when you're suffering or sick. And some people reported that wasn't happening. Exactly. So kind of like the time that you really, really needed, that's when you sort of learn who your true friends are is when during periods of sort of illness or adversity, like who are the people who are coming in and helping you and bringing you food or driving you to the airport or so the doctor's office.
你知道的，我觉得感受到爱往往与感受到被理解高度相关。所以当人们觉得，我没有真正被看到、被理解时，这个人从来不问我关于，你知道的，我的这个爱好，忘记了生日，你知道的，通常正是这些类型的事件真正加深了这种感觉，即我没有感受到爱。还有当人们遭受痛苦或生病时，我的意思是，当你在经受痛苦或生病时，你真的很希望有人来关心你。而一些人报告说这并没有发生。确实如此。所以就像在你最最需要的时候，那正是你了解谁才是真正的朋友的时候，正是在生病或逆境等时期，看究竟是谁在伸出援手、给你送食物、开车送你去机场或是去医生办公室。
Yeah. So those are kind of events that really sort of, as I said, kind of illuminate or. telling, but not feeling love can come in any kind of moments during the day. So it doesn't have to be only during sort of important events of our lives. You found that the ways people go about trying to feel more loved are often misguided and sometimes counterproductive. One thing we do is try and manage or manipulate the other person into saying or doing what we want them to do. I want to play you a clip from the movie The Breakup. Jennifer Aniston plays a woman, and Brooke is involved with Gary, played by Vince Vaughn.
是的。所以这些正是那种正如我所说，能够照亮问题或说明问题的事件。但感受不到爱可能发生在一天中的任何时刻。所以它不一定只发生在我们生活中的重要时刻。你发现，人们试图去感受更多爱的那些方式往往是带有误导性的，有时甚至会适得其反。我们所做的一件事情就是试图掌控或操纵对方，让他们说出或做出我们希望他们说或做的事。我想放一段电影《分手男女》中的片段。詹妮弗·安妮斯顿饰演女主角布鲁克，她与文斯·沃恩饰演的加里谈恋爱。
Now in this scene, Brooke talks to Gary as he plays a car-themed video game. Well, I'm going to go do the dishes. Cool. It'll be nice if you help me. No problem. We'll get them a little bit later. I'm just going to get the streets here for a little bit. Gary, come on.
在这场戏中，布鲁克一边对正在玩赛车主题电子游戏的加里说话。好了，我要去洗碗了。酷。要是你能帮帮我就好了。没问题。我们待会儿再洗吧。我先在这儿把街道跑完再说。加里，拜托。
I don't want to do them later. Let's just do them now. Take 15 minutes. Oh, honey, I am so exhausted. I just honestly want to relax for a little bit. If I could just sit here and we will, you know, we can clean the dishes tomorrow. Here, you know, I don't like waking up to a dirty kitchen. I cares.
我不想待会儿再洗。我们现在就洗吧。花个15分钟。哦，亲爱的，我累坏了。我老实说，只想放松一会儿。如果我能就坐在这里，然后我们，你知道的，我们可以明天再洗碗。听着，你知道的，我可不想一醒来面对的就是个脏厨房。谁在乎啊。
I care, all right? I care. I busted my ass all day, cleaning this house, and then cooking that meal. And I worked today. It would be nice if you said thank you and helped me with the dishes. Fine. I'll help you do the damn dishes. Oh, come on.
我在乎，好吗？我在乎。我累死累活一整天，打扫这房子，然后做那顿饭。我今天也上班了。你要是能说声谢谢并帮我洗碗，那就太好了。好吧。我来帮你洗该死的碗。哦，拜托。
You know what? No. That's, see, that's not what I want. You just said that you want me to help you do the dishes. I want you to want to do the dishes. Why would I want to do dishes? Why? See, that's my whole point.
你知道吗？不用了。看吧，那不是我想要的。你刚才不是说想要我帮你洗碗吗？我是希望你想去洗碗。我为什么会想洗碗？为什么？看吧，这就是我的全部重点。
Sonia, what do you hear when you listen to that exchange? First of all, I've so been in that situation. Mostly as Brooke, but I think I'm baby on both sides. This is so similar to that show couples therapy, except it's fiction. So it's like Brooke is not feeling loved because he's not seeing her. He's not seeing how important it is for her to sort of get the dishes done. And so then they can really go about their evening. And then to her, it just seems like this is so easy.
索尼娅，当你听到这段对话时，你有什么感受？首先，我太经历过那种情况了。大部分时候我是布鲁克，但我觉得两边我都扮演过。这和那个《夫妻治疗》节目太像了，只不过这是虚构的。所以这就好比布鲁克感觉不到被爱，因为他没有看到她。他没有看到把碗洗完对她来说有多重要。这样他们才能真正享受他们的夜晚。然后对她来说，这似乎太简单了，
easy, it's just 15 minutes of your time. And so she's like she's not feeling loved by his response. And of course, what Brooke is really asking in this case is actually not help with the dishes. She's actually asking for something else altogether. She's asking really to be seen and heard. She needs him to kind of, yes, Bakerfield-Lept. As she memorably says, she doesn't want him to do the dishes. She wants him to want to do the dishes. And I've totally been in that situation where I'll complain like why. And like my husband used to say, and he's like, look, I'm helping you do the dishes, like literally with the dishes.
太简单了，只需要你15分钟的时间。所以她觉得他的回应让她感受不到被爱。当然，布鲁克在这种情况下真正要求的其实并不是帮忙洗碗。她实际上要求的是完全不同的东西。她真正要求的是被看到和被听到。她需要他能够，对，像贝克斯field-Lept说的那样。正如她令人难忘的台词所说，她不是要他洗碗。她是希望他自己想去洗碗。我完全经历过那种情况，我会抱怨说为什么。我丈夫以前会说，他说，听着，我这不是在帮你洗碗吗，字面意思上的洗碗。
Like, I'm doing it. Like, I don't need to be happy doing it was his response. And I'm like, no, but I want you to be happy doing it, which is really the same kind of thing. Another way that we go about trying to make others love us is by making ourselves as physically attractive as possible. We think that looking good will win us the love that we see. seek. Talk about this strategy and whether it's effective. Right. And I'd like to broaden it, not just physical attractiveness, but sort of other characteristics what we think, like, if only I were more
就像，我在洗啊。我不需要洗得高高兴兴的，这就是他的回应。而我说，不，但我希望你洗得高高兴兴的，这其实是完全一样的心理。我们试图让别人爱我们的另一种方式，是通过让自己在身体上尽可能具有吸引力。我们认为外表好看就能赢得我们所寻求的爱。谈谈这种策略以及它是否有效。没错。而且我想把它扩大化，不仅是身体上的吸引力，还包括其他特征，我们认为，比如，只要我更
physically attractive, then I'd be more loved. If only I were more successful, I would feel more loved. These are called extrinsic goals, right, which is like beauty, fame, power, money, popularity, right? If only I had those things, I would feel more loved, or I would get more love. And then we try to show that off, right? Sort of broadcast. those positive qualities. And it doesn't work. It might work to impress a person, but it doesn't work to actually make us feel more love. And if you're kind of broadcasting this, you know, if you're just, it's all about physical
有身体吸引力，我就会获得更多爱。只要我更成功，我就会觉得更被爱。这些被称为外在目标，对吧，比如美貌、名望、权力、金钱、受欢迎程度，对吧？只要我拥有这些东西，我就会觉得更被爱，或者我会得到更多的爱。然后我们试着把这些展示出来，对吧？也就是广播般地宣扬那些积极的品质。但这不管用。它或许对给某人留下好印象有效，但对于真正让我们感受到更多的爱毫无用处。如果你把这些宣扬出去，你知道的，如果你只是，这全都是关于你的身体
attractiveness for you or about your accomplishments. It doesn't really show the person your kind of true self, you know, if you will. It's just showing them this sort of outside little positive, shiny part that isn't really you. And this is the guy who's telling you. all about his Tesla car. Exactly. And actually, I had another date where the guy just went on and on, and he's actually a storyteller by his profession. So he's a great storyteller, and he went on and on telling all these funny stories. And after 45 minutes, and it impressed me. It did impress me.
吸引力或者你的成就。这并没有真正向对方展示你真实的自我，如果你愿意这么说的话。它只是向他们展示了外面那个小小的积极、光鲜的部分，而那并不是真正的你。这就是那个跟你大谈特谈他的特斯拉汽车的家伙。完全正确。事实上，我还有过另一次约会，那个家伙没完没了地讲个不停，而且他的职业恰好是个讲故事的人。所以他是个很棒的讲故事者，他滔滔不绝地讲着所有这些有趣的故事。在45分钟之后，他确实给我留下了深刻印象。我的确留下了深刻印象。
I thought, oh, he's funny, he's smart, he's charming, he's witty. I did think that was true, but I really didn't feel a connection with him. And after 45 minutes, I stopped him. And I said, do you realize that for the last 45 minutes, you have not asked me a single question? I remember one of our previous guests on Hidden Brain talked about how, you know, we know about IQ and some of us know about EQ, which is, you know, emotional intelligence. But there's also what they call ZQ, which is the person who asks zero questions. And so where are you on the ZQ scale? Are you somebody who asked zero questions or a lot? Well, I think question asking is one of the most sort of underestimated social skill. In fact, I tell my kids, you know, like, if you want to make friends, ask people questions about themselves, especially questions that, about things that they, you know, that their friends care about.
我想，哦，他很有趣，他很聪明，他很有魅力，他很机智。我的确觉得那是真的，但我真的没有感觉到与他之间有什么连接。在45分钟后，我打断了他。我说，你有没有意识到，在过去的45分钟里，你甚至没有问我一个问题？我记得我们之前在 Hidden Brain 的一位嘉宾曾谈到，你知道的，我们了解智商（IQ），我们有些人了解情商（EQ），也就是所谓的（情感智商）。但还有一种他们所说的 ZQ，也就是问零个问题的人（Zero-Question）。所以你在 ZQ 量表上处于什么位置？你是一个问零个问题的人，还是会问很多问题？好吧，我认为提问是最被低估的社交技能之一。事实上，我告诉我的孩子们，你知道的，比如，如果你想交朋友，就去问别人关于他们自己的问题，尤其是那些关于他们，你知道的，他们的朋友所关心的事情的问题。
Yeah. And so, and in fact, Nick Eppley, who's a professor at University of Chicago, has done these studies that show that people think that, like, if they ask personal questions, that they are going to be perceived as kind of intrusive or too probing, to personal, but actually, on average, we crave to be asked. Like, we want to be asked about our lives, our inner lives, you know, what we really think about something, what our childhood was like. So not only do we try and present ourselves as very beautiful or try and, you know, talk up our accomplishments or our skills or our talents, we also go to some lengths to hide parts of ourselves that are unappealing or might be unlovable.
是的。而且，事实上，芝加哥大学教授尼克·埃普利（Nick Eppley）做过这些研究，结果表明人们认为，如果他们问个人问题，会被人视为具有侵入性或盘问太多、太私事，但实际上，平均而言，我们极度渴望被提问。就像，我们希望别人问起我们的生活、我们的内心世界，你知道的，我们对某事的真实想法，我们的童年是什么样的。所以，我们不仅试图把自己表现得非常美丽，或者试图，你知道的，吹嘘我们的成就、技能或才华，我们还会费尽心机去隐藏自己身上那些没有吸引力或可能不可爱的部分。
Talk about this strategy. We often hide our blemishes. in order to feel more loved, but does that work? Right, because we think that that person wouldn't love me anymore if they kind of knew about this weakness of mind, this fault of mine, or this bad deed that I made. And, you know, we're not always wrong, right? I mean, sometimes people really do dislike others
谈谈这种策略。为了感受到更多的爱，我们常常隐藏自己的瑕疵，但这管用吗？对，因为我们觉得如果那个人知道了我的这个弱点、这个缺点，或者我曾经做过的这件坏事，他们就不会再爱我了。而且，我们并不总是错的，对吧？我的意思是，有时人们确实会因为某些特质或行为而不喜欢别人，但我们做得太过火了。我们做得太多了。而感受到爱的关键之一，是让对方真正了解你。如果你把自己的脆弱、矛盾、那些凌乱的内心隐瞒起来，不让对方看到，你就不会感受到爱，因为你总是会想，如果他们真的了解我，就不会爱我了。事实证明，当我们以合适的节奏向对方袒露或展示其中一些矛盾或瑕疵时，对吧？我们不是把它们一次性全部倒出来。当对方已经对我们有了一定了解时，我们往往实际上会更受人喜爱。
for certain traits or behaviors, but we do it. We sort of overdo it. We do it too much. And one of the keys to feeling loved is being known to the other. And if you're hiding, you know, your vulnerabilities, your contradictions, your sort of messy insights from the other person, you won't feel love because you'll always wonder if they really knew me, then they wouldn't love me. And it turns out that we often, when we disclose or show some of those contradictions or blemishes at the right pace, right? We don't sort of dump them all at once. When the person already knows us a little bit, we often actually better liked.
你知道的，有个著名的例子，肯尼迪在猪湾事件后承认自己犯了一个错误，他的支持率反而飙升了。所以有时承认失败实际上可以增加人们对我们的喜爱。当然，在人际交往中，索尼娅，你知道的，我希望你喜欢我，不仅是因为我的成就和才华，我更需要你在我真正脆弱的地方给予我爱。如果我没有真正分享我脆弱的地方或者我有瑕疵的地方，那么正如你所说，我所经历的全部就是你因为我的才华和品质而钦佩我，而不是因为，你知道的，是什么造就了真正的我。所以你感到的是被钦佩。你感到，是的，就像你给对方留下了深刻印象。
You know, there's this famous case when JFK, after the Bay of Pigs, admitted to making a mistake, and his approval ratings shot up. So sometimes admitting failures can actually increase people's liking of us. And of course, at interpersonal setting, Sonia, you know, I want you to like me, not just for my accomplishments and my talents, but I need the love in the places where I'm actually vulnerable. And if I'm not actually sharing the places where I'm vulnerable or where I have blemishes, then, as you say, all I experience is that you're admiring me for my talents and my qualities, not for what, you know, what makes me me. So you feel admired. You feel, yeah, like you're impressed.
你给对方留下了深刻印象，但你并没有真正感受到被爱。当你想到无条件爱的定义时，我的意思是，这基本上就是无条件爱的含义，那就是无论我们有何瑕疵和缺点，我们依然被爱着。谈谈这样一种观点：我们在处理人际关系时所做的大部分事情，实际上都属于表演的范畴，而不是真正建立连接。因为当你谈论这里描述的所有不同策略时，谈论我们的金钱、汽车、财富、才华、能力，我们有多会讲故事，你知道的，我们有多会讲笑话。所有这一切都是表演。是的，这是表演。而且，你知道的，这非常人性化。
You're impressed out the other person, but you don't actually feel loved. When you think about the definition of unconditional love, I mean, that's basically what unconditional love is, is that we're loved despite our blemishes and some of our flaws. Talk about the idea that a lot of what we're doing when we are engaged in relationships really falls under the realm of performance rather than connection. Because when you talk about all the different strategies that you're describing here, talking up our money, our cars, our wealth, our talents, our abilities, how well we tell stories, you know, how well we can tell jokes. All of this is performance. Yeah, it's performance. And, you know, it's very human.
你知道的，我们所有人都会这么做。也许那是对话中作为社会润滑剂的一部分吧。但实际上，顺便说一句，我认为对话确实是感受爱的关键。你知道的，当你想到一段关系时，它实际上就是一系列对话。所以改变这些对话是关键，让它们少一点表演性，多一些关于更深层次的连接，真正进行更深层的对话。真正能让你让对方感受到爱的，正是那些更深层次的对话。当我向你表现出真诚的兴趣，尚卡尔，并问你，你知道的，比如最近几周有什么事让你担心吗？你心里一直在想什么，你知道的，什么事，你知道的，跟我说说一个让你担心或者让你感到非常高兴的亲戚或某段关系，你知道的，正是这些类型的问题让我们彼此感觉联系更紧密，你知道的，而不只是试图给对方留下深刻印象。
You know, we all do it. And maybe that's part of the kind of social lubricant that is part of a conversation. But really, by the way, and I think conversations are really the key to feeling loved. You know, when you think about a relationship is really a series of conversations. So changing those conversations is the key to make them a little bit less performative and more about, like, deeper connection, really having deeper conversations. It's really the deeper conversations that make you make the other person feel of. When I show genuine interest in you, Shankar, and ask you about, you know, maybe has anything been worrying you, you know, the last few weeks? What's been on your mind, you know, what's, you know, tell me about a relationship, a family member that you are worried about or that you're really happy about, you know, those are the kinds of questions that make us feel more connected to each other, you know, not just trying to impress each other.
我想知道社交媒体在这些习惯和偏好中可能扮演什么角色，索尼娅，因为现在，现在越来越多的人，你知道的，通过这些数字媒介相互交谈，他们在向其他人展示一张面具。你在展示你自己。我是那种喜欢这种音乐的人。我是那种基本上会去这种度假的人。我是那种穿着这种衣服的人。我想在某种程度上，社交媒体正在放大我们的表演驱动力。绝对是的。
I'm wondering what role social media might play in these habits and preferences, Sonia, because now, Now increasingly, you know, people talk to one another across these digital mediums and they're presenting a face to other people. You're presenting yourself. I'm someone who likes this kind of music. I'm someone who basically goes on these kinds of vacations. I'm someone who wears these kinds of clothes. And I would imagine that in some ways social media is amplifying our drive to perform. Absolutely.
绝对是的。人们在发布他们生活中最美好的时刻，对吧？这是我在度假时看起来非常棒的样子。他们并没有发太多关于他们生活全貌的内容。对吧。但感受爱确实需要一种舞蹈。我更倾向于从两个人对话的角度来考虑它，尽管参与者可能多于两个人，
Absolutely. People are posting sort of their most positive moments in their lives, right? This is me on my vacation looking really great. they're not posting so much about the sort of the fullness of their life. Right. But feeling loved requires really kind of a dance. And I'd like to think of it in terms of two people talking, although it could be more than two people,
但思考双人互动会更简单一些，此时你真正在观察周围的氛围。你真正在读懂对方，并向他们提出恰到好处深度的提问，让他们觉得被真正看到和听到，并且我向他们展示了我真的很在乎。你在社交媒体上是做不到这一点的。你知道的，那种效果传达不出来。你知道的，所以这就是为什么，如果一个朋友在社交媒体上分享了一个非常搞笑的笑话，你知道的，我可能会欣赏它，但我真正感激的是，如果他们通过电子邮件或发短信把那个笑话发给我，因为我觉得他们是在，你知道的，他们想到了我。他们认为我会真正欣赏这一点，这就在我们之间建立了一种连接。
but it's just easier to think about a dyad where you're really reading the room. You're really reading the other person and asking them just the right level of deep question where they feel like they're really seen and heard, and I'm showing them I really care. You can't do that on social media. You know, it doesn't come off. You know, so that's why, like, if a friend shares a really funny joke on social media, you know, I might appreciate it, but I really appreciate it, is they, if they email me or they text me with that joke, because I feel like they are, you know, they're thinking about me. They think that I would really appreciate that, and that forges a connection between us.
抛出暗示并钓取赞美，试图让自己看起来很好并显得令人印象深刻，努力呈现出一个光鲜完美的形象。我们以为这些策略会带给我们所寻求的爱。当它们不管用时，我们会变本加厉。我们试图表现得更加完美，更加令人印象深刻，把最微小的瑕疵也隐藏起来。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何真正地感受到爱。你正在收听的是 Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Dropping hints and fishing for compliments, trying to look good and appear impressive, striving to present a polished and perfect image. we think that strategies will bring us the love we seek. When they don't, we double down. We try to come across as even more perfect, be ever more impressive, hide the tiniest flaws. When we come back, how to feel loved, for real. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
这里是 Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你的生活中是否经历过感觉不被爱的时刻？你是否有过这种感觉，甚至当你身处那些表面上爱你的人身边时也是如此？具体是什么让你觉得没有得到关怀？如果你有一个愿意与 Hidden Brain 听众分享的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录下一段语音备忘录。两到三分钟就足够了。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Have you experienced moments in your life when you felt unloved? Did you feel that way, even when you were? around people who ostensibly loved you. What was it specifically that made you feel uncared for? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty.
将其发送到我们的邮箱 Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org，主题行请写：Feeling Loved（感受被爱）。再重复一遍，邮箱是 Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org。心理学家索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基和哈里·里斯是《如何感受爱：让你收获最多重要之物的五种心态》一书的作者。索尼娅，我们一直在讨论人们试图从他人那里获得关怀时所采用的策略。我们试图让自己变得更美丽、更有成就或毫无瑕疵。这些方法都基于这样一种观点：为了被爱，我们必须变得更可爱。
Email it to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org using the subject line, Feeling Loved. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Psychologists Sonia Lubomirsky and Harry Rees are the authors of how to feel loved, the five mindsets that get you more of what matters most. Sonia, we've been talking about the strategies people deploy when they're trying to feel cared for by others. We try to make ourselves more beautiful or more accomplished or flawless. And these approaches are based on the idea that in order to be loved, we have to become more lovable.
而你说这通常不管用。相反，我们更有可能通过创造合适的关系条件来达到感受到爱的状态。你这是什么意思？我的意思是，我们认为要感受到更多的爱，我们需要改变自己，也就是让自己变得更可爱，同时展示我们有多可爱，隐藏我们的瑕疵。或者也许我们去改变对方。
You say that this usually doesn't work. Instead, we are more likely to arrive at a state of feeling love. by creating the right relational conditions. What do you mean by this? What I mean by this is that we think that to feel more loved, we need to change ourselves, sort of make ourselves more lovable and also show how lovable we are, hide our blemishes. Or maybe we change the other person.
也许我们试图让他们更爱我们，以某种方式让他们更多地看到我们的积极品质。但实际上，这是个好消息。我和哈里得出的结论其实是个好消息，那就是你不需要改变自己。你不需要改变对方。你需要改变的是对话。而一段关系，再次强调，就像是一系列对话。
Maybe we try to get them to love us more, to somehow see our positive qualities more. But actually, it's good news. The conclusion that Harry and I reached is actually good news. which is that you don't have to change yourself. You don't have to change the other person. What you have to change is the conversation. And a relationship, again, is like a series of conversations.
这样想的话，事情就会少很多压倒性的负担。事实上，我们在写这本书时获得的另一个巨大启发是，如果我想让自己感受到爱，第一步是试着让对方感受到爱。这才是真正排在第一位的东西。这与直觉相悖，因为我们觉得，再次强调，我们的注意力集中在自己身上，当出现问题时，把注意力集中在自己身上、找出哪里出了问题，这在进化上对我们是有适应意义的。但在这里，情况恰恰相反，真正的焦点需要放在对方身上，通过了解对方，让对方感受到爱。
And it's a lot less overwhelming to think about it that way. And actually, another huge insight that we had writing the book is that if I want to make myself feel loved, the first step is try to make the other person feel loved. That's really what comes first. And it's counterintuitive because we think like, again, we were focused. focusing ourselves, it's very, again, it's evolutionarily adaptive for us when there's a problem to focus on ourselves, figure out what's wrong. But here's a situation where really the focus needs to be on the other person, is to get the other person to feel loved by getting to know
这样想会让人觉得轻松很多。事实上，我们在写这本书时得到的另一个巨大感悟是，如果我想让自己感受到爱，第一步就是努力让对方感受到爱。这才是真正首要的。这与直觉相悖，因为我们又会陷入自我关注。再次强调，当出现问题时，我们关注自己、找出问题所在，这在进化上是对我们有适应意义的。但在这里，重点确实需要放在另一个人身上，即通过去了解对方，让对方感受到爱。
them better. So let's unpack some of these things, but let's start with the basic idea. You argue that by demonstrating interest in others, that is one way, in some ways, of eliciting interest from others. So there is a norm of reciprocity that is at work here. Exactly. And the reciprocity norm or reciprocity principle is really one of the strongest principles of human social behavior. It's very, very powerful. This is why if I want you to do me a favor, you know, I do you a favor, right? It's very, very hard for us not to reciprocate, not to return the favor. And so we're talking here in the context of conversation that what I
更了解彼此。所以让我们来剖析其中的一些事情，但我们先从最基本的概念开始。你认为，通过对他人表现出兴趣，这是在某种程度上激发他人对你产生兴趣的一种方法。所以这里面起作用的是一种互惠规范。完全正确。而互惠规范或互惠原则确实是人类社会行为中最强大的原则之一。它非常非常强大。这就是为什么如果我想让你帮我个忙，你知道的，我会先帮你一个忙，对吧？我们很难不进行互惠，不回报这份恩情。所以我们这里讨论的是，在对话的语境下，我
show genuine curiosity to you, Shankar, and I really listened to. really listen to your answers and I'm asking you questions that are that show that I'm listening that take take what you said maybe to a new level. It's going to be very compelling for you to return that favor and to sort of direct that attention back to me that asks me questions about my life, my inner life and listen to me. And so it's kind of a, it's a dance or sort of a dynamic that goes back and forth. Now, of course, a lot of people are going to say, you know, Sonia and Harry are telling me that at precisely the point that I feel unloved, at Precisely the point that I feel like this other person is dropping the ball.
向你展现出真诚的好奇心，香卡，我真的在听。真的在听你的回答，并且我向你提问，这些问题表明我在倾听，并且把你说的话或许提升到了一个新的水平。这会让你非常想要回报这份恩情，将注意力重新转向我，向我提问关于我的生活、我的内心生活的问题并倾听我。所以这有点像是一支舞蹈，或者是一种来回往复的动态过程。现在，当然，很多人会说，你知道的，索尼娅和哈里告诉我，恰恰在我感到缺乏爱的时候，恰恰在我感觉对方在掉链子的时候。
They are telling me I need to pay attention to that person instead of demanding that that person pay attention to me. You and Harry came up with a metaphor to explain your idea that you call the relationship seesaw. First, explain the term seesaw. You have an interesting spelling for the term and how this metaphor works. Yes. But I want to also, I'm going to do that,
他们告诉我，我需要去关注那个人，而不是要求那个人来关注我。你和哈里想出了一个隐喻来解释你们的观点，你们称之为“关系跷跷板”。首先，请解释一下“跷跷板”这个词。对于这个词你们有一个有趣的拼法，以及这个隐喻是如何运作的。是的。但我也想——我会讲到这个，
but I also want to sort of validate you. that yes, it seems so counterintuitive, kind of at the lowest point where you really want to feel love to sort of advise people to show interest in the other person, but that's exactly what is needed and to really ask the person, why is it that they are responding the way they are? You know, it's showing curiosity in them. And by the way, and I do also want to add a caveat, which is that once in a while, it's not going to work. It's going to fail. The other person is is not going to respond, they're not going to reciprocate. That is going to happen once and a while, and maybe that means that you need to walk away or you need to pause or you need to try something
但我同时也想对你的感受表示认可。是的，这听起来太反直觉了，在感觉最低谷、最渴望感受到爱的时刻，却去建议人们对另一个人表现出兴趣，但恰恰需要这么做，并且去真诚地询问对方，为什么他们会有那样的反应。你知道的，这是对他们表现出好奇心。顺便说一句，我也想补充一个注意事项，那就是偶尔这不会起作用。它会失败。对方不会做出反应，他们不会回报。这种情况偶尔会发生，或许这意味着你需要走开，或者你需要暂停，或者你需要尝试一些
different or you accept the fact that that's how it's going to be. And so I don't want, I'm not a polyana and I don't think that it's going to work 100% of the time, but I think it's very, very powerful what we're talking about. So the seesaw, we spell sea like underwater. And the reason we spell it this way is this idea that there's a seesaw underwater. and we're sort of partially submerged and sort of say you and I are sitting on opposite end of the seesaw. So most of us are submerged, but maybe the top of our heads or the top of ourselves are showing. And that's what's going on in most of the world. Like we're showing just like a little tip of ourselves to one another, just kind of maybe the shiny parts, maybe the positive qualities, right?
不同的方法，或者接受事情就是会这样的事实。所以我不希望——我不是一个盲目乐观的人，我不认为它百分之百的时间都会奏效，但我认为我们正在谈论的这个方法非常非常强大。所以关于跷跷板，我们将“sea”（海洋）拼写为像水下那样的“sea”。我们这样拼写的原因是这个想法：水下有一个跷跷板。我们有点部分浸没在水中，比如说你和我坐在跷跷板的两端。所以我们大多数人都沉在水下，但也许我们的头顶或我们自身的顶部露出来了。这就是世界上大多数地方正在发生的事情。就像我们向彼此只展示了很小一部分自我，可能只是闪闪发光的部分，也许是积极的品质，对吧？
Most of us, like it's kind of the iceberg, right, it's under the water. We're not really showing to each other. And then the idea is that again, we're sitting on the seesaw. And then when I show genuine curiosity and interest in you, and I ask you a question, what has been on your mind lately, and I show warmth and acceptance, you feel a sense of warmth and trust and safety. And it's as though I'm pressing down on the seesaw. And it lifts you up a little bit.
我们大多数人，就像一座冰山一样，对吧，它在水下。我们并没有真正向彼此展现。然后这个想法是，我们再次坐在跷跷板上。接着，当我向你表现出真诚的好奇心和兴趣，并且我问你一个问题，“你最近一直在想什么？”，我表现出热情和接纳，你就会感受到一种温暖、信任和安全感。这就好像我在向下压跷跷板。它把你向上托举了一点点。
It lifts you up a little bit. So you're able to show a little bit more of yourself to me, right? You're able to reveal a little bit more of your inner self, a little more of your full self, maybe some vulnerabilities. And then as you do that, as you talk about maybe your childhood and how difficult it was, I listen really well to you. I'm really listening. I'm asking questions. And that makes you even more, you know, feeling even more safe and trusting and even more comfortable, you know, sort of lifting more of yourself out of the water. And then that reciprocation happens, right?
它把你向上托举了一点点。所以你能够向我多展露一点自我，对吧？你能够揭示更多一点你的内心世界、更多一点完整的自我，也许还有一些脆弱面。然后当你这样做的时候，当你谈论也许你的童年以及它是多么艰难时，我非常认真地倾听你。我真的在倾听。我在提问。这让你更加——你知道的，感觉更加安全、信任，甚至更加舒适——你知道的，把更多的自己托举出水面。然后这种互惠就发生了，对吧？
and then you ideally then reciprocate and then show interest and curiosity in myself and lift me out of the water. So it's kind of a process of I lift you and then you lift me and this lifting and being lifted. And I love the metaphor of the seesaw because initially when you are lifting effectively the other person out of the water, you're actually doing more to submerge yourself. You're putting more of yourself under the water so that the other person can be lifted out. But of course, if you think about the natural movement of a seesaw, yes, it goes up on one side, but then it goes up on the other side. And that's what happens.
然后理想情况下，你会进行互惠，接着对我表现出兴趣和好奇心，把我也托举出水面。所以这有点像是一个过程：我托举你，然后你托举我，这种托举与被托举。我喜欢跷跷板这个隐喻，因为最初当你有效地将另一个人托举出水面时，你实际上做得更多的是把自己浸没在水中。你把更多的自己放在水下，这样另一个人才能被托举出来。但是当然，如果你想想跷跷板的自然运动，是的，它在一边会升起，但接着它在另一边也会升起。这就是所发生的事情。
It goes back and forth. When you show genuine interest and warmth and listening towards the other person, it helps them be comfortable and helps them open up. It helps us to know each other better. And then they reciprocate. In your book, you describe a very talented listener named Marco. Tell me what Marco does and how it really shows. the power of listening in helping the other person raise themselves out of the ocean.
它来回往复。当你对另一个人表现出真诚的兴趣、热情和倾听时，这能让他们感到舒适，并帮助他们敞开心扉。这有助于我们更好地了解彼此。然后他们会给予回报。在你的书中，你描述了一个非常有天赋的倾听者，名叫马克托。请告诉我马克托做了什么，以及这如何真正展现了倾听在帮助另一个人将自己从海洋中托举出来的力量。
So Marco was the best listener I've ever met in my life. And I don't know how he became such a great listener if it's just like genetic. I do think we can learn to be better listeners. But he also had a great memory too. So most of us listen to respond. Right. So we're kind of like, while we're listening ostensibly, we're really rehearsing what we're going to say next, right? right and we're kind of waiting for the mic to be given back to us when you think about it so this guy marco was not doing this like he was listening uh to learn you know listening to learn is like listening like there's going to be a quiz tomorrow right and you would remember everything and you would say oh sonya remember that time you were telling me about your you know your mom and this happened
所以马克托是我一生中见过的最好的倾听者。我不知道他是怎么成为这样一个伟大的倾听者的，这是否只是出于基因。我的确认为我们可以学会成为更好的倾听者。但他也有很好的记忆力。所以我们大多数人倾听是为了回应。对吧。所以我们有点像，当我们在表面上倾听时，我们实际上在心里排练我们接下来要说的话，对吧？对，我们有点在等待话筒被交回给我们，仔细想想的话。所以这家伙马克托没有这样做，他是带着学习的目的去倾听的——你知道的，带着学习去倾听就像是明天的考试要考一样，对吧？你会记住一切，你会说：“哦，索尼娅，还记得你跟我讲过关于你的——你知道的，你的妈妈，以及发生这件事的时候吗？
and you were wearing a red that red dress and you were sitting over there it's so incredibly compelling right because you feel like, wow, he really cares about me. Like, he's very thoughtful. He's paying attention, right? And by the way, I don't have that kind of memory. So we can't remember the red dress. It doesn't mean that we're not a good person. But this guy really was a prodigy at listening.
你穿着一件红色的——那件红色的裙子，你坐在那边。”这太不可思议地吸引人了，对吧？因为你会觉得，哇，他是真的很关心我。就像，他非常体贴。他在全神贯注，对吧？顺便说一句，我没有那种记忆力。所以我们可能记不住红色的裙子。这并不意味着我们不是一个好人。但这家伙在倾听方面确实是个奇才。
You know, I can't remember who told us this story. But someone told us the story on Hidden Brain some time ago about former president Bill Clinton, who famously was able to make every person in a room feel like, you know, they had, his full attention. But they told us this wonderful story about Clinton when he was governor of Arkansas visiting, I think, a middle school and talking to the various kids there and asking, what do you want to be when you grow up? And one of the kids, you know, who was a little cheeky, said, I want to be you when I grow up. This is a middle schooler. And so everyone has a good laugh. And then Clinton, you know, leaves the governorship of Arkansas. He becomes
你知道，我记不清是谁给我们讲过这个故事了。但不久前，有人在《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）节目上给我们讲了关于前总统比尔·克林顿的故事。他以能让房间里的每个人都觉得——你知道的，他们获得了他全部的注意力而闻名。但他们给我们讲了一个关于克林顿的精彩故事：当他是阿肯色州州长时，去访问，我想是一所初中，与那里的各种孩子交谈，并问：“你们长大后想做什么？”其中一个有点调皮的孩子说：“我长大后想成为你。”这是一个初中生。于是大家都开怀大笑。然后克林顿——你知道的，卸任了阿肯色州州长。他成为了
president of the United States. And at one point, he goes back to the South during a natural disaster. and there are thousands of people who are waiting to see him, and there's a rope line with, like, and he's greeting thousands of people and shaking hands. And after doing two hours of this, he's at an intersection, and he looks over the intersection three rows back, and he reaches out and shakes this guy's hand who's now eight years or ten years older than he was in middle school,
美国总统。有一次，在发生自然灾害期间，他重返南方。有成千上万的人在等着见他，那里有一道警戒线，而且——他正在迎接成千上万的人并与他们握手。在做了两个小时这样的事情之后，他在一个十字路口，他越过十字路口向三排开外望去，然后他伸出手去握了这个家伙的手。这个家伙现在比他上初中时大了八岁或十岁，
and Clinton asks him, do you still want to be me? That is such a moving story. My God, I love that story so much. And I've heard that, too, right? like he'll remember like your cousin's wedding happen and how did that go. And, you know, most of us don't have that kind of memory. So we don't feel, I don't think we need to feel bad if we don't. But charismatic people like Bill Clinton, he's really like a prodigy.
克林顿问他：“你还想成为我吗？”这真是一个令人动容的故事。天哪，我太喜欢这个故事了。而且我也听说过类似的事情，对吧？比如他会记得你的表亲的婚礼是什么时候举行的，以及进展得怎么样。而且，你知道的，我们大多数人都没有那种记忆力。所以我们不觉得——我认为如果我们没有，也不需要感到难过。但像比尔·克林顿这样有个人魅力的人，他真的就像个奇才。
They make you feel like you're the only person in the room. Like you're the only person in the world when you're talking to them. You know, there's a story. And again, I may not even get it right. And it may be apocryphal, but it's a story about when Gladstone was running for Prime Minister against Disraeli. and a woman sat next to each of them in sort of consecutive fundraising nights. And after she sat next to Gladstone, she was asked, oh, how was your dinner?
他们让你觉得你是房间里唯一的人。当你跟他们交谈时，就像你是世界上唯一的人。你知道，有一个故事。再次申明，我甚至可能记不准细节。它可能是个传说，但这是一个关于格莱斯顿（Gladstone）竞选首相时对阵迪斯雷利（Disraeli）的故事。一位女士在连续两个晚上的募捐晚会上分别坐在他们两人的旁边。在她坐在格莱斯顿旁边之后，有人问她：“哦，你的晚餐怎么样？”
And she said, oh, it was such a lovely dinner. I had such a lovely time I had with him. He's just the cleverest man in all of England. And then the next night she sits next to Desirelli and the same question. And they asked her, how was your night? And she said, oh, that was such a wonderful time with him. I feel like I'm the cleverest woman in all of England. Right?
她说：“哦，这是一场如此美妙的晚餐。我和他度过了一段非常美好的时光。他简直是全英国最聪明的人。”然后第二天晚上她坐在迪斯雷利旁边，面对同样的问题。他们问她：“你昨晚过得怎么样？”她说：“哦，和他在一起度过了一段非常美妙的时光。我觉得我是全英国最聪明的女人。”对吧？
And that is exactly what Bill Clinton and charismatic people do. Instead of making them feel good about themselves, they make you feel good about yourself. And again, it's curiosity and listening and ask you questions about yourself. And they draw out your wit or your kindness or your interestingness, your intelligence. That's the key. You also say it's important to genuinely keep our hearts open to the other person. In other words, it's not just how we look, what we say, how we listen, but inside, where the other person can't see us at all,
这正是比尔·克林顿和富有个人魅力的人所做的事。他们不是让你觉得自己很棒，而是让你觉得自己很棒。同样，这是通过好奇心、倾听，并问你关于你自己的问题。他们激发了你的机智、你的善良、你的趣味性、你的智慧。这就是关键。你还说过，保持我们对另一个人的心真正敞开是很重要的。换句话说，这不仅仅取决于我们的外表、我们所说的话、我们如何倾听，而是在内心深处——那个别人完全看不到的地方，
to actually keep our heart open to the other person. Describe what you mean by this, Sonia. You know, and this is, in some ways, this is actually the most common attribute of relationships is, you know, most of us in relationships that are sort of intact, whether it's a friendship or a romantic relationship or collegial relationship. You know, we tend to have an open heart toward the other person,
要真正向另一个人敞开心扉。索尼娅，请描述一下你这是什么意思。你知道的，从某种意义上说，这实际上是人际关系中最常见的属性，你知道的，我们大多数人在某种程度上完好的关系中，无论是友谊、浪漫关系还是同事情感。你知道的，我们往往对另一个人怀有一颗敞开的心，
which means we have warmth towards them. We wish them well. want them to be happy. We're kind to them. We care about them. So actually, it's pretty common to have that open heart. But it's important to sort of to maintain that, because that sense of warmth, it helps the other person, as we talked about, to open up, right? When we're really warm and kind and our eyes show, sometimes, I mean, I have friends, they look at me with loving eyes. It's really one way to think about it. It's so wonderful. And that warmth gives us a sense of safety and trust and helps this to open up and become more known and sort of we can become
这意味着我们对他们充满温暖。我们祝愿他们一切顺利。希望他们快乐。我们对他们很好。我们在乎他们。所以实际上，拥有一颗敞开的心是很常见的。但重要的是要保持这种状态，因为这种温暖感能帮助另一个人——正如我们所讨论的那样——敞开心扉，对吧？当我们非常温暖、善良，并且我们的眼神流露出——有时候，我的意思是，我有朋友，他们用充满爱的眼神看着我。这真的是一种思考方式。太美妙了。这种温暖赋予我们安全感和信任感，并有助于我们敞开心扉，变得更为主动地被了解，某种程度上我们可以变得
and then to feel more loved. You know, I think many of us look at people who are good communicators, good listeners, and we say, okay, I need to do these four different things. I need to look the other person in the eye. I need to ask them questions. I need to show interest. I need to ask follow-up questions. And yes, you can do all of those things.
然后感受到更多的爱。你知道，我认为我们许多人看着那些善于沟通、善于倾听的人，然后我们会说：“好吧，我需要做这四件不同的事情。我需要直视对方的眼睛。我需要向他们提问。我需要表现出兴趣。我需要提出后续问题。”是的，你可以做所有这些事情。
But at some level, if you're not actually interested in the other person, we are very very good at picking up, you know, fakery, very good at picking up people who are not sincere. And in some ways, when you talk about keeping an open heart to someone, what you're saying is it's not just what you're showing on the outside that matters. You actually have to, at some level, feel it on the inside. Exactly. Exactly. And actually, the definition of what's called high quality listening is kind of the psychological term for really good listening is basically you're paying attention, I'm paying attention to your words, I'm understanding your words, and also I care about what you're saying, right? And that last part is really important.
但在某种程度上，如果你实际上对另一个人不感兴趣，我们非常非常善于察觉——你知道的，虚伪，非常善于察觉那些不真诚的人。在某种程度上，当你谈到对某人保持一颗敞开的心时，你的意思是，这不仅仅是你外在表现出来的东西重要。你实际上在某种程度上必须在内心感受到它。完全正确。完全正确。事实上，所谓的高质量倾听的定义——这是真正好的倾听的心理学术语——基本上就是你在关注，我在关注你的话语，我在理解你的话语，同时我也在乎你所说的话，对吧？而最后一部分真的很重要。
Like, I actually care, right? And so that warmth, that kindness, yeah, it's so critical. It's kind of a symptom, right, that the other person really cares. And as you said, like, we can tell it's, you can't fake it. You know, we are very, it's good. It's evolutionarily adaptive again for us to be good inauthenticity detectors, right? Because those are maybe people that we don't want to invest a lot of time with. I understand that when you and Harry were writing your book, you spent some time in a coffee shop talking about this notion of keeping your heart open and other patrons in the coffee shop overheard your conversation and came over on their own volition to share ideas with you. Describe for me what happened. It was actually incredible. So this was
就像，我实际上是在乎的，对吧？所以这种温暖、这种善良，是的，它是如此关键。这有点像是一个信号，对吧，表明另一个人是真的在乎。正如你所说的那样，我们能分辨出来，你无法假装它。你知道的，我们非常——从进化角度来看，对我们来说再次具有适应性，让我们成为优秀的真实性探测器，对吧？因为那些可能是我们不想投入大量时间去交往的人。我了解到，当你和哈里在写书时，你们曾花了一些时间在一家咖啡馆里讨论这种保持敞开心扉的概念，咖啡馆里的其他顾客无意中听到了你们的对话，并自发地走过来与你们分享想法。请描述一下当时发生了什么。这其实太不可思议了。所以这是
like in January, last January, in Brooklyn, New York, it was sort of a dark, you know, kind of dark, like a cold day. And so, and this has never really happened any time, because I'm often in coffee shops talking to people, but I've never been sort of approached so consistently by others. So we were sort of brainstorming ideas for our book. And I would say at least three different people just came up to us and started talking to us.
就像去年一月，在纽约布鲁克林，那是那种昏暗的、你知道的，有点阴暗、寒冷的日子。所以，这种情况以前从来没有发生过，因为我经常在咖啡馆里和人们交谈，但我从来没有被其他人如此持续地主动搭讪过。所以我们当时正在为我们的书头脑风暴构思。我想至少有三不同的人径直向我们走来，开始和我们交谈。
Like, you know, and some of them were, one of them was really shy and said, I'm really sorry to interrupt, but I want to tell you. So they heard it we were talking about feeling, loved. And so they gave us different stories from their lives. Instead of one woman, maybe 28 or something, her boyfriend, I think, lives in Mexico, she said. And so it's really hard for them to sort of maintain that relationship as long distance. And so she mentioned how they have this shared Spotify list. And so on a regular basis, they will add songs to the shared list that are meaningful to them. And that makes them feel loved. Another person said that he and his partner have a, uh, a,
就像，你知道的，其中一些人——其中有一个人真的很害羞，并说：“我真的很抱歉打扰你们，但我想告诉你们。”所以他们听到我们在谈论感受到爱。于是他们讲述了各自生活中的不同故事。比如有一位女士，大概28岁左右，她说她的男朋友住在墨西哥。所以他们很难维持那种远距离的关系。因此她提到他们有一个共同的Spotify播放列表。所以他们会定期向这个对他们意义重大的共享列表中添加歌曲。这让他们感到被爱。另一个人说他和他的伴侣拥有一个——呃，
have a picture frame that has a picture of the two of them, and it lights up kind of randomly throughout the day. And when it lights up, they send each other a word, it's just one word that sort of expresses their feelings. And it could be love. It could be yearning. It could be curiosity. It could be loneliness, right?
拥有一个相框，里面有两人的合影，它在一天当中会随机亮起。当它亮起时，他们会向对方发送一个词，仅仅是一个词，用来表达他们的感受。这可能是“爱”。可能是“渴望”。可能是“好奇”。也可能是“孤独”，对吧？
Sort of lonely. And that makes them feel love to feel like that they really feel connected to the other person. And it was so beautiful. It was so beautiful that people kept like they want. like they wanted to share, which made us think that, like, wow, this is really hitting a nerve. People really think a lot about this, about feeling love, not feeling love, what maintains feeling loved, what gets people to fall out of that feeling loved. It's really on people's minds a lot.
有点孤独。这让他们感受到爱，觉得他们与另另一个人的连接真实存在。这太美好了。太美好了，人们一直——就像他们想要分享一样，这让我们觉得，哇，这真的触动了人们的神经。人们真的很经常考虑这个问题：关于感受到爱、没有感受到爱、是什么维持了爱的感觉、是什么让人们失去了爱的感觉。这确实经常占据人们的心头。
One of the things that I think happens in long-term relationships, especially, Sonia, is that we start to forget how complicated people are and how much they change. Can you talk a moment about how being open to another person means, of accepting that they are complex people and that they're not fixed in stone. So just because someone, you know, goes out to a party doesn't mean that they're an extrovert. They could have different sides to them. Talk about this idea that our embracing of complexity, both our own complexity and the complexity of other people, helps us forge closer relationships.
索尼娅，我认为在长期的关系中尤其会发生的一件事是，我们开始忘记人们有多么复杂，以及他们改变了多少。你能花一点时间谈谈，对另另一个人的开放意味着接受他们是复杂的人，而不是一成不变的吗？所以，仅仅因为某人——你知道的，去参加一个派对，并不意味着他们就是一个外向的人。他们可以有不同的一面。谈谈这个观点：我们对复杂性的拥抱——无论是我们自己的复杂性还是他人的复杂性——如何帮助我们建立更紧密的关系。
Yeah, I think this is so important. And, you know, we've been talking about the importance of sharing and listening and getting known and being known. Well, some of that might involve me telling you a story that might involve some sort of a contradiction or something that's maybe not so positive about me or something that, like, you don't really understand why did she do this. And so I think it's important for us to respond with, I guess you would say, with acceptance, you know, that you really accept the other person, that the idea that we're all a quilt or a tapestry of many, many, many qualities. And, you know, I have this trauma, yes, but it doesn't define me. have, you know, sometimes I'm kind, but you know what? Sometimes I'm selfish. And sometimes I'm loyal. Sometimes I'm a little narcissistic. And we all have that. We all have that. And how do we
是的，我认为这非常重要。而且，你知道的，我们一直在谈论分享、倾听、被了解和了解彼此的重要性。其中一些可能涉及我给你讲一个故事，其中可能包含某种矛盾，或者某些关于我来说可能不是那么积极的事情，或者像你真的不明白“她为什么要这么做”的事情。所以我认为对我们来说，用——我想你可以说是用接纳来回应是很重要的，你知道的，你真正接纳另一个人，我们所有人都是由许多许多品质拼凑成的拼布或挂毯。你知道的，我有这种创伤，是的，但它并不定义我。我有——你知道的，有时我很善良，但你知道吗？有时我很自私。有时我很忠诚。有时我有点自恋。我们都有这些。我们所有人都有。以及我们如何
sort of turn off that sort of judgmental tendency is when we hear someone's story that sort of doesn't quite make sense? You know, how do we respond to that? And I think that's actually one most challenging things to do. You told me that there were times when you didn't feel loved by your daughter, even though you knew that she did love you. I'm more. wondering whether your research has informed how you went about seeking love from her? You know, when I didn't feel loving by my daughter, I thought, like, maybe I should talk to her and ask her, you know, what is it? And somehow I thought that, I don't know, like, I could change something about myself or about her. But what the research behind the book taught me is to start with showing interest in her and showing interest in her in her life and sort of what makes her tick and start to ask questions about
当听到某人的故事感觉有些说不通时，如何关掉那种好为人师的评判倾向？你知道的，我们该如何回应？我认为这实际上是最具挑战性的事情之一。你告诉我，有时候你觉得你的女儿不爱你，尽管你知道她是爱你的。我更想知道的是，你的研究是否对你如何向她寻求爱产生了影响？你知道的，当我感觉不到女儿的爱时，我想过，也许我应该和她谈谈，问问她，你知道的，是怎么回事？不知何故我以为，我不知道，也许我可以改变自己身上的一些东西，或者改变她身上的东西。但书背后的研究所教给我的，是先从对她表现出兴趣开始，对她生活中的事物表现出兴趣，对是什么让她充满活力表现出兴趣，并开始提出关于以下内容的问题：
the things that are really exciting to her, which may not be exciting to me, at least not initially. And so I started to spend more time with her, I started to ask her more questions and sort of to listen more, and then to follow up too, right? So maybe follow up, maybe a week later, a month later, say, hey, I remember when you told me you were interested in that, you know, what is happening there? You know, sort of to follow up because then she sees that I remember the things that really matter to her and to make her feel loved first. Did that work? Did it change her behavior? Yeah, you know, it did.
那些让她真正兴奋的事情，虽然这些事情可能对我来说并不兴奋，至少一开始不是。所以我开始花更多时间陪伴她，我开始问她更多问题，并且更多地倾听，然后还要进行跟进，对吧？所以也许进行跟进，也许在一周后、一个月后说：“嘿，我还记得你告诉我你对那个感兴趣，你知道，现在进展怎么样了？”你知道的，进行跟进是为了让她看到我记得那些对她真正重要的事情，并首先让她感受到被爱。这起作用了吗？这改变了她的行为吗？是的，你知道的，确实起作用了。
Now, it didn't have some kind of immediate miraculous, you know, result, but it led her to open up a little bit more to me. It led her to ask me more questions about me, which is, you know, not as common. You know, children often don't ask their parents a lot of questions. It made me think like, oh, I should go call my mom and ask her more questions. Maybe we should all do this after this episode. call your parents and ask them questions about their inner lives or about their childhoods, about what really matters to them. And also it sort of led us to be more affectionate with each other.
当然，它并没有带来某种即时、奇迹般的结果，但它引导她对我稍微敞开了一点心扉。它引导她问我更多关于我自己的问题，你知道的，这不太常见。你知道的，孩子们通常不会问父母很多问题。这让我觉得，哦，我应该去给我妈妈打电话，问她更多问题。也许我们在这一集之后都应该这样做。给你的父母打电话，问他们关于他们内心生活或童年的问题，问问什么对他们真正重要。而且这也有助于我们彼此之间变得更加亲密。
I'm a huge fan of physical touch. It's like I just feel so loved, you know, when we're cuddling, you know, and so we've been cuddling a lot more lately. As Sonia Loper Merski notes, when we don't feel loved, our thoughts often turn inward. We ask ourselves, what is it about me that others? don't like. When a classmate in school doesn't want to be our friend, we may tell ourselves, we're not cool enough. When a potential employer doesn't hire us, we fear it's because we're not smart enough. How do we prevent these sorts of thought patterns from becoming self-fulfilling
我是身体接触的超级粉丝。这就好像我只是感到如此被爱，你知道的，当我们拥抱的时候，你知道的，所以我们最近一直在更多地拥抱。正如索尼娅·洛珀-梅尔斯基（Sonia Lupin-Merski）所指出，当我们感觉不到被爱时，我们的想法往往会转向内。我们会问自己：“我身上有什么是别人不喜欢的地方？”当学校里的同学不想和我们做朋友时，我们可能会告诉自己：我们不够酷。当潜在的雇主不录用我们时，我们担心这是因为我们不够聪明。我们如何防止这类思维模式变成自我实现的
prophecies? Recently, the psychologist Greg Walton told me a story. He works at Stanford University and also went to school there. At an alumni event, a woman approached him with an anecdote of She said when she was a kid, she loved soccer, and she told her father that she was going to try out, walk on to the Stanford Women's soccer team, which is a very good team. Walking onto a college sports team is never easy. Most of the players are recruited by coaches. The process is highly competitive with lucrative scholarships on the line. Joining the team as a walk-on would require a ton of hard work. The woman's father didn't believe she was capable of that.
预言？最近，心理学家格雷格·沃尔顿（Greg Walton）给我讲了一个故事。他在斯坦福大学工作，也曾在那里上学。在一次校友活动上，一位女士走近他，讲述了一个轶事。她说，当她还是个孩子时，她热爱足球，她告诉父亲她要尝试去选拔并进入斯坦福女子足球队，这是一支非常优秀的队伍。以非特招身份加入大学运动队从来都不是一件容易的事。大多数球员都是由教练招募的。这个过程竞争极其激烈，还伴随着丰厚的奖学金。以旁听生身份加入球队需要付出大量的艰辛努力。这位女士的父亲不相信她有这个能力。
And her father said, you're not going to go there three weeks early and get up every morning at whatever hour. Like, I don't believe you. And she told me that she did do that. After the woman received negative feedback from her father, she could have let it stop her. She could have believed that she wasn't good enough or dedicated enough. Instead, she chose to focus on a positive compliment she'd received years earlier.
她的父亲说：“你不会提前三个星期去那里，并且每天早晨在不管几点钟都爬起来。我不相信你。”她告诉我说，她确实做到了。在受到父亲的负面反馈后，这位女士本可以让它阻止她。她本可以相信自己不够优秀，或者不够投入。相反，她选择专注于她几年前收到的一句正面赞美。
And the reason she did that was because when she was a kid playing on a youth soccer team, she overheard a parent on a different team saying, hey, like that number 23, which was her number, she's really good. And she held that in her heart and in her mind as she came to Stanford, as she walked on to the Stanford's women's team, and as she made the team and made a career out of, the soccer business. When we consider our own abilities,
她之所以这样做，是因为当她还是个在青少年足球队踢球的孩子时，她无意中听到另一个球队的家长说：“嘿，看那个23号——那是她的号码，她真的很棒。”她把这句话铭记在心，并带着这个信念来到斯坦福，加入了斯坦福女子足球队，成功入选了球队，并将足球事业发展成了她的人生职业。当我们审视自己的能力时，
how do we keep fears and doubts from turning into beliefs? After the break, Greg Walton answers listener questions and comments about the science of self-fulfilling prophecies and how to avoid negative thought spirals.
我们如何防止恐惧和怀疑变成信念？休息之后，格雷格·沃尔顿将回答听众关于自我实现预言的科学原理以及如何避免消极思维螺旋上升的问题和评论。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When we realized that we failed at something, it's hard to focus on anything else. Our minds tell us over and over
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。当我们意识到自己在某事上失败时，很难把注意力集中在其他任何事情上。我们的大脑一遍又一遍地告诉我们
that we are weak, we're lazy, we are stupid. This negative train of thought can lead to painful questions. Why am I not good enough? Do others hate me? One fear bleeds into another. Soon, we don't even remember
我们很软弱，我们很懒惰，我们很愚蠢。这种消极的思维惯性会导致痛苦的问询。为什么我不够好？别人讨厌我吗？一种恐惧蔓延到另一种恐惧。很快，我们甚至记不清
where the negativity started. Down we descend into a vortex of doom. How do we find our way out of such negative thought spirals? At Stanford University, psychologist Greg Walton studies how our minds can entrap us and what we can do to avoid these traps. Greg is the author of Ordinary Magic, the Science of How We Can Achieve Big Change with Small Acts. He joined us on a recent episode of Hidden Brain titled U2.0 Stop Spirling.
消极情绪是从哪里开始的。我们不断下沉，坠入厄运的漩涡。我们如何才能摆脱这种消极的思维螺旋？在斯坦福大学，心理学家格雷格·沃尔顿研究了我们的思维如何将我们困住，以及我们可以做些什么来避开这些陷阱。格雷格是《平常的魔法：通过微小行动实现巨大改变的科学》（Ordinary Magic, the Science of How We Can Achieve Big Change with Small Acts）一书的作者。他最近参加了《隐藏的大脑》名为“升级2.0：停止螺旋失控”（U2.0 Stop Spirling）的一期节目。
Today, he's back on the show to respond to your questions and comments about that episode. Greg Walton, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Greg, I'm going to start by playing you a story of a listener who called in. Her name is Sherry, and she shared how she struggled with negative thought spirals as a young woman. It really escalated quite a bit as I grew out of my teens and into my 20s, that it started to become so bad, you know, all of these thoughts about how I wasn't living up to who I should be. That was stupid.
今天，他重返节目，来回答你们关于那一期节目的问题和评论。格雷格·沃尔顿，欢迎再次来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。格雷格，我首先要播放一个打进电话的听众的故事。她的名字叫雪莉（Sherry），她分享了自己年轻时如何与消极思维螺旋作斗争。随着我走出十几岁、进入二十多岁，这种情况真的升级了很多，以至于开始变得非常糟糕，你知道的，所有这些关于我没有达到我应该成为的样子的想法。这太蠢了。
You shouldn't have said that. Why did you do that? Regrets about the past. These kinds of terrible looping thoughts that at some point had me thinking about suicide quite a bit. Because I just didn't think that there was a way out of all of that. I'm going to come back at the end of the show, Greg, with more of Sherry's story. Sherry tells us how she got out of her doom loop. But for now, can you start by talking about Sherry's experience of spiraling?
你本不该那样说。你为什么那样做？对过去的悔恨。这些可怕的循环想法，在某个时候甚至让我考虑过自杀。因为我只是觉得根本没有办法摆脱这一切。格雷格，节目结束时我会带着雪莉故事的更多内容回来。雪莉告诉我们她是如何摆脱厄运循环的。但现在，你能先谈谈雪莉陷入思维螺旋的经历吗？
what she went through is hardly unique, is it? No, of course, not at all. So that experience of having one bad thought kind of primed the next thought. So I did something bad, I'm bad, I did something else bad, I'm really bad. That vortex, as you describe it, makes a lot of sense, and I think it's something that everybody can relate to. You talk about some of the reasons we might spiral. We heard from a listener named Lucia, who writes,
她所经历的绝不是个例，对吧？不，当然，完全不是。所以那种有一个糟糕的想法，从而引发下一个想法的经历。所以我做了一件坏事，我很坏；我做了另一件坏事，我真的很坏。正如你所描述的那样，那个漩涡非常合乎情理，我认为这是每个人都能感同身受的事情。你谈到了一些我们可能会陷入螺旋的原因。我们收到了一个名叫露西亚（Lucia）的听众的来信，她写道：
our 16-year-old son is in a downward spiral because of a hiccup on his schedule this year. He's a junior in high school. He's given up on school. He thinks his life is ruined. He has a very fixed mindset, and it is very difficult for him to get unstuck. We're having a hard time supporting him through this and would love some insight. We taught Greg in our previous conversation about how people often overreact to setbacks in their lives. we blow small pieces of information out of proportion.
我们的16岁儿子因为今年日程安排上的一个小波折而陷入了消极的螺旋。他是高二学生。他对学校放弃了。他认为自己的人生被毁了。他有一种非常固定的思维模式，而且他很难摆脱这种状态。我们很难在这段时期支持他，并希望能得到一些见解。我们在之前的对话中教给格雷格的是，人们经常对生活中的挫折过度反应。我们将一小块信息放大到了不成比例的程度。
You talked about the idea of something called a TIFBIT. Can you remind us what a TIFBet is? Sure, of course. A TIFBit is a tiny fact that you have a big theory about and then you react to it in a big way. So the teacher maybe says something unkind and you think, she thinks I'm dumb, I'm checking out. I'm not participated in this class anymore.
你谈到了一个叫做“微小事实论”（TIFBIT）的概念。你能提醒我们什么是TIFBit吗？当然，没问题。TIFBit是一个微小的事实（tiny fact），你对它抱有一个宏大的理论，然后做出巨大的反应。所以老师可能会说一句不太友善的话，你就会想：她觉得我很笨，我要放弃了。我再也不会在这个班上参与互动了。
That would be an example of a TIFBet. So when it comes to a young person, somebody who is in high school, I mean, it's hard to imagine the kind of setback this person could have that could justify them feeling like their life is ruined when they're a junior in high school. And yet this must happen all the time. People in high school must constantly feel, my God, whatever happened this past week in school, it's so huge that it must mean the rest of my life has no future. Yeah. Well, I think the thing to think about there is we're talking about Adela. who are in the process of developing from being children into the adults they'll be.
这就是一个TIFBit的例子。所以当谈到一个年轻人，一个高中生时，我的意思是，很难想象这个人能遭遇什么挫折，能证明他们觉得自己当了高中生时人生就被毁了是有道理的。然而这种事一定一直在发生。高中生们一定经常觉得，天哪，过去这一周在学校发生的事太大了，以至于这意味着我的余生都没有未来了。是的。嗯，我认为需要思考的是，我们谈论的是青少年。
So, you know, suppose you're a kid, you're 15 years old, and you want to join, maybe it's the newspaper club, and maybe you get excluded from that. In your mind, you might be thinking, now I can't be the newspaper journalist that I wanted to become. You might not have that thought fully consciously, but the rejection from the club might feel like a rejection from the future self that you are aspiring to. Lucia writes that her son has a fixed mindset. What are fixed mindsets and how do they lead to these kinds of thought spirals?
他们正处于从儿童向未来成年人发展的过程中。所以，你知道，假设你是个孩子，你15岁，你想加入——也许是校报俱乐部，也许你被排除在外了。在你的心中，你可能会想：现在我不能成为我想成为的那名报社记者了。你可能没有完全有意识地这样想，但被俱乐部拒绝可能会让人感觉像是被你渴望的未来的自己所拒绝。露西亚写道，她的儿子有一种固定的思维模式。什么是固定思维模式？它们是如何导致这类思维螺旋的？
Yeah, a fixed mindset is the idea that you have a certain amount of intelligence. That's what you have. And you're either smart or you're not smart. And there's not much you can do to increase that. And if you have that fixed mindset and you approach a learning situation, maybe you take a math test, if you don't do very well, that fixed mindset tells you're not good at this. You're not a math person. You shouldn't try at this. And it leads people to become unre resilient when they're faced with learning challenges. You've done research looking at how
是的，固定思维模式是指这样一种观点：你拥有特定数量的智力。这就是你所拥有的。要么你很聪明，要么你很不聪明。而且你没有太多办法来增加它。如果你拥有这种固定思维模式并接近学习情境，也许你参加了一场数学考试，如果你考得不是很好，这种固定思维模式就会告诉你：你并不擅长这个。你不是学数学的人。你不应该在这上面尝试。这导致人们在面对学习挑战时变得毫无韧性。你做过研究，探讨过
students can avoid spirals and cultivate what's called a growth mindset. So for a parent like Lucia, who is basically dealing with the 16-year-old son who feels like his life is over, how would you recommend she deploy this idea of a growth mindset to help her son, Greg? Yeah. So I think one thing to say is that Lucia's role is one important role as a parent, and there's other people around that child, too, including all of the educators around them who are playing important roles, and all of the peers around that child as well. And what all of those actors want to be able to do in that circumstance is really talk about the value of learning and growth and the opportunity for learning and growth. So when you make a mistake, it's not a sign that you're dumb.
学生如何避免螺旋并培养所谓的成长型思维模式。所以对于像露西亚这样一位母亲来说，她基本上要应付一个觉得人生完蛋了的16岁儿子，你建议她如何运用成长型思维模式的概念来帮助她的儿子，格雷格？是的。所以我觉得有一点要说的是，露西亚作为母亲扮演着重要的角色，而且那个孩子身边还有其他人，包括周围所有扮演着重要角色的教育工作者，以及孩子身边的所有同龄人。在那种情况下，所有这些行动者都希望能够做到的，是真正去谈论学习和成长的价值，以及学习和成长的机会。所以当你犯错时，这并不是你变笨的信号。
That would be a TIFBIT. It's a sign that you haven't gotten something yet. You know, just in the same way that a toddler who falls down as they're learning to walk, they're not a non-walker, right? They're just a child who hasn't yet gotten the competency of walking. So in math class, if you fail a test, that means you don't understand that material. yet. And the parents' role and the teacher's role and the peers' role is all to come together to support that learning process, to play their roles well. And for the parent, that might be about encouragement. For the teacher, it might be saying, I'm going to be with you every step of the way as you work on this material and it's hard and I'm going to give you the right materials.
那会是一个TIFBit。这表明你有些东西还没学会。你知道的，就像一个在学走路时摔倒的幼儿，他们并不是一个“不会走路的人”，对吧？他们只是一个尚未掌握走路技能的孩子。所以在数学课上，如果你考试不及格，这意味着你还不理解这些材料。而父母的角色、老师的角色和同龄人的角色，所有这些汇聚在一起支持那个学习过程，扮演好他们的角色。对父母来说，这可能是鼓励。对老师来说，可能是说：“当你在处理这些材料、觉得很难时，我会陪伴你走过每一步，我会为你提供正确的材料。”
And when you ask a question that's helping me become a better teacher because you're helping me understand what it is you don't know yet and how I can respond to you in ways that we'll support that learning growth that you're on. We heard from another parent named Melissa who writes, I've noticed that young kids these days, including my own, seem to treat every small bump in the road as a large catastrophe. I try to talk to my kids and encourage them not to see it like this. Now, as we've discussed, Greg, adolescence is a dramatic time in our lives.
“当你问问题时，这能帮我成为一个更好的老师，因为你帮我理解了你还不知道什么，以及我该如何以支持你学习成长的方式来回应你。”我们收到了另一位名叫梅利莎（Melissa）的家长来信，她写道：我注意到现在的年轻人，包括我自己的孩子，似乎把路上的每一个小坎坷都当成了巨大的灾难。我试图和我的孩子交谈，鼓励他们不要这样看待问题。现在，正如我们所讨论的，格雷格，青春期是我们生命中戏剧性的时期。
Do you know if teenagers are more prone to negative spirals than younger kids or older adults? I don't know of data that has asked that question directly. I would not be surprised, though. I had an opportunity this past fall to do a couple of different events for Stanford alum talking about people's experiences in the transition to college. And in these events, I talked about how it's very common to worry about whether you belong when you come to college and when you have an initial difficulty, maybe a conflict of a with a roommate, that can sometimes seem if you're 18 years old, like maybe that's a sign that people like me don't belong here. You know, it was so interesting in doing these events with alum, people who are now in their 40s and their 50s and their 60s and their 70s is they all recalled back to that time and said, absolutely, yes, when I was 18, it felt like the world was riding on that.
你知道青少年是否比更小的孩子或成年人更容易陷入消极螺旋吗？我不知道有没有直接探讨过这个问题的具体数据。不过，如果真是这样，我也不会感到惊讶。去年秋天，我有机会为斯坦福校友举办了几场不同的活动，谈论人们在向大学过渡时的经历。在这些活动中，我谈到：当你刚上大学时，担心自己是否能融入其中是非常常见的，当你遇到最初的困难时，也许是与室友产生冲突，如果你才18岁，这有时可能看起来像是一个信号，表明像我这样的人不属于这里。你知道的，在与校友——现在40多岁、50多岁、60多岁、70多岁的人——一起举办这些活动时，非常有趣的是，他们都回想起那个时期并说：绝对是的，当我18岁时，感觉全世界都押注在这上面。
Like the world was riding on, you know, whether I was going to have a good relationship with my roommate or what did my professor say to me when I asked a question in class or did I get a, you know, a B plus or an A minus on that chemistry test, right? From the perspective of a 45 rule, that's in the distant past, right? And nothing is really riding on that now, but they could recall back to what that was like and how important that felt for the student at that time. Sometimes negative thought spirals can be triggered by what we think is happening
就像全世界都押注在——你知道的，我是不是能和室友搞好关系，或者当我在课堂上提问时教授对我说什么，或者我在那场化学考试里得了B加还是A减，对吧？从一个45岁的人的角度来看，那已经是遥远的过去了，对吧？现在没有任何事情押注在那个上面，但他们能够回想起那是什么感觉，以及这对当时的学生来说是多么重要。有时，消极思维螺旋可能是由我们认为正在发生的事情引发的
in the minds of other people. We got a message about this from a listener named Linda. She writes, When I worked as a nurse, there was an on-call administrator I needed to call maybe once a month. Whenever he'd answer, he sounded negative and perturbed. I always felt like he didn't like me because his tone seemed like he was saying, great, it's you again bothering me. One day, I was standing within earshot when his phone rang.
在其他人的脑海中。我们收到了一位名叫琳达的听众发来的关于这方面的消息。她写道，当我当护士时，有一个我可能一个月左右需要打一次电话的待命管理员。每当他接电话时，他听起来都很消极和烦躁。我总是觉得他不喜欢我，因为他的语气似乎在说，太好了，又是你来烦我。有一天，我站在刚好能听到他说话的范围内，这时他的电话响了。
I heard him answer in the exact same tone he'd been answering when I had called. This is when I realized that it wasn't me, that that was simply how he answered, his phone. So Greg, in previous episodes of the show, we've explored the errors we make when we try to read the minds of other people. Talk for a moment about how these faulty assumptions can shape our tendency to spiral. Yeah, right? So the listener is learning that this person she's interacting with is actually just a grump, right? So it's actually about him. It's not about her. All of us kind of look out at the world from a kind of self perspective. Like you're reading the world from the perspective of yourself.
我听到他用和我打过去时一模一样的语气接听了电话。这时我才意识到，这并不是针对我，那只是他接电话的方式。格雷格，在节目的前几集里，我们探讨了当我们试图猜测其他人的想法时所犯的错误。请谈一谈这些错误的假设是如何塑造我们陷入恶性循环的倾向的。是的，对吧？所以这位听众了解到，她正在与之交流这个人其实只是个脾气暴躁的人，对吧？所以这其实是关于他自己的事。这与她无关。我们所有人都倾向于从一种自我视角来看待外面的世界。就像你是从你自己的视角来解读世界一样。
And so you're asking the question kind of, you know, what does this have to do with how I'm seeing? What does this have to do with me? What does it have to do with my abilities? What does this have to do with how they're evaluating me or what my prospects might be? And sometimes we can neglect the fact that it might be about them, it might be about their their own stuff that's going on inside of them. And then when something negative happens, like a brusque interpersonal experience, you can think very easily, they don't like me,
所以你提出的大致问题是，你知道的，这和我看到的有什么关系？这和我有什么关系？这和我的能力有什么关系？这和他们如何评估我或者我的前景可能会怎样有什么关系？有时我们可能会忽略这样一个事实，即这可能与他们有关，可能与他们内心正在发生的他们自己的事情有关。然后，当消极的事情发生时，比如一次生硬的人际交往体验，你很容易就会想，他们不喜欢我，
they don't believe in me, they don't respect me, and that can, you know, kick off a downward spiral. I'm wondering if this is also magnified when we're dealing with people who in some ways have power over us. So if you're thinking about a small child interacting with her parents, for example, or a kid in a classroom interacting with a professor, you know, it's understandable that we pay a lot of attention now to the affect and behavior of this other person because this other person has power over us. And now perhaps we're even more likely to overinterpret their moods, their attitudes, the way they speak as being somehow referential to us. Yeah, absolutely, right? So I'm reminded of an older French movie called.
他们不信任我，他们不尊重我，这可能会，你知道的，引发一场恶性循环。我想知道，当我们面对那些在某些方面对我们拥有权力的人时，这种现象是否也会被放大。因此，如果你想到一个幼儿与她的父母互动，例如，或者课堂上的一个孩子与教授互动，你知道的，我们可以理解的是，我们现在会密切关注这个其他人的情感和行为，因为这个其他人对我们拥有权力。现在，也许我们甚至更有可能过度解读他们的情绪、态度、他们说话的方式，认为这些在某种程度上是指向我们的。是的，完全如此，对吧？所以我想起了一部老法国电影，叫做……
called the class in which there is a teacher who's teaching a group of students, many of whom are immigrants, and there's an African immigrant student in the class. And the African immigrant student finds out that the teacher who he believes most in, who he thinks believes in him, has said something about him. And there's this classroom confrontation that elicits what that thing is that that teacher had said about that student. And what the word is that the teacher had said was limited. And the student, the immigrant student, hears that this is the word that his favorite teacher has said about him. And he physically deflates. He collapses into his chair. And then maybe 30 seconds later in the film, he erupts in an incredible display of anger. And you can feel how devastating
这部电影叫《课间好时光》，片中有一位老师正在教导一群学生，其中许多是移民，班上还有一个非洲移民学生。这个非洲移民学生发现，他最信任的老师——他认为信任他的那位老师——说了一些关于他的话。班级里出现了一场对质，引发了老师对那个学生说过的话的内容。老师说出的那个词是“局限”。而这个学生，这个移民学生，听说这就是他最喜欢的老师对他的评价。他的精气神瞬间垮了下来。他瘫倒在椅子上。然后大约在电影的30秒后，他爆发出令人难以置信的愤怒。你能感受到那是多么具有毁灭性……
that is, how absolutely devastating that is. When someone you look up to, someone who has power over you, someone who might know something that you don't know, foresees for you, a future that is limited, sees in you a lack of capacity. It is absolutely devastating. And the inverse is also incredibly true and incredibly powerful. So there is, I don't think, anything more powerful or more special, then when you're struggling, when you don't know which way to go, when you're lost or you're confused or you're getting into conflicts, and somebody believes in you and they see in you the good and the successful person that you can become, and they share that image for you, and they play their part to help you realize that image. I think that is, that's bringing ordinary magic to your
那绝对是毁灭性的。当你所仰望的人，一个对你拥有权力的人，一个可能知道一些你不知道的事情的人，为你预言了一个有限的未来，在你身上看到了能力的匮乏。这绝对是毁灭性的。而反过来也同样无比真实且极具力量。所以，我认为没有任何东西比以下情境更有力量或更特别了：当你挣扎时，当你不知道该走哪条路时，当你迷失方向、感到困惑或陷入冲突时，而有人相信你，他们在你身上看到了你可以成为的那个善良且成功的人，他们为你分享了那个形象，并扮演他们的角色来帮助你实现那个形象。我认为，那是，那是为你的生活带来普通魔法。
life. When we come back, how our framing of negative events causes us to spiral downwards or upwards. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At times it feels like bad things come in threes, fours, even tens. One setback leads to another, and another. And soon, this destructive snowball has gathered so much momentum, it feels like it will crush us. At Stanford University, psychologist Greg Walton studies how these avalanches grow and how we can stop them. Today, he joins us to answer your questions about his work.
稍后回来，我们将探讨我们对消极事件的框架是如何导致我们向下或向上陷入螺旋式发展的。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。有时感觉坏事接二连三、接四连十地发生。一次挫折引发又一次挫折，接连不断。很快，这个破坏性的雪球积聚了如此之大的动量，让人感觉它会把我们压垮。在斯坦福大学，心理学家格雷格·沃尔顿研究这些雪崩是如何形成的以及我们该如何阻止它们。今天，他来到我们节目中，回答您关于他工作的提问。
Greg, we heard from a listener named Suzanne. She says she has struggled with spiraling almost her whole life. It started when she was very young. When I was 19, my sister was 21, she choked to death. And so, of course, now I have a fear of choking. If I come down late at night, my husband is sitting in front of the TV eating peanuts, I start worrying that he's going to choke on the peanut, and I'm going to come down in the morning and find him dead. And it's something that I get a little bug in my mind about it initially, and then it starts to play out, and it gets darker and darker and darker until I find myself literally in an absolute panic situation. that jump to disaster thinking has become so automatic that sometimes I don't even realize it's happened until I'm in it.
格雷格，我们收到了听众苏珊的一条消息。她说她几乎一生都在与陷入恶性循环作斗争。这一切始于她很小的时候。当我19岁时，我姐姐21岁，她窒息身亡。所以，当然，我现在有了窒息的恐惧。如果我深夜下楼，看到我丈夫正坐在电视机前吃花生，我就会开始担心他会被花生噎住，而我早上下来时会发现他已经死了。起初这只是我脑子里的一点小苗头，然后它开始发酵，变得越来越黑暗、越来越黑暗，直到我发现自己真的陷入了绝对恐慌的状态。这种直接跳到灾难性想法的思维模式变得如此自动化，以至于有时我甚至没有意识到它已经发生了，直到我身陷其中。
But it's a lifelong process for me, and I love your program. Thank you so much. So, Greg, we talked about TIFBits, how we can sometimes blow small bits of information out of proportion. But in some cases, terrible things can and do happen to us. When our spirals are caused by real events, not by our imaginations, what can we? do about them. It's no longer enough to say, stop and look at reality accurately. Yeah, I really appreciate Suzanne's question. And I want to just share a story from my own experience. So when I first moved back to Stanford as a professor, I was bicycling home one night through a dark street.
但对我来说这是一个毕生的过程，我非常喜欢您的节目。非常感谢。所以，格雷格，我们讨论了信息碎片，我们有时如何将微小的信息碎片夸大。但在某些情况下，可怕的事情确实可能而且已经发生在我们身上。当我们的恶性循环是由真实事件而非我们的想象引起时，我们能怎么做？对它们采取行动。仅仅说“停下来，准确看待现实”已经不够了。是的，我非常感谢苏珊的问题。我也想分享一个我自己的经历中的故事。所以当我最初作为教授搬回斯坦福时，有一天晚上我正骑着自行车穿过一条黑暗的街道回家。
And it was dark and I was going too fast. And all of a sudden there was a car right in front of me. This is a residential street. The car had a bike rack on it. And I rear-ended this parked car. And the bike rack sliced open my face. Shunk, I don't know if you can see. I have a scar here. And it was terrible.
当时天很黑，我骑得太快了。突然一辆汽车就在我眼前。这是一条住宅街道。车上装着一个自行车架。我追尾了这辆停着的汽车。那个自行车架割开了我的脸。尚卡尔，我不知道你能不能看见。我这里有一道疤痕。这太可怕了。
I got myself home. There was a lot of blood. You know, I didn't ride a bike for maybe six months after that. And I walked every day. And then when I did start to ride a bike, I did it very slowly and I did it very carefully. So, you know, one thing I want to say is just how normal and reasonable Suzanne's response is to remember the trauma of the experience with her sister
我自己回到了家。流了很多血。（你知道的）在那之后的六个月左右我都没有骑自行车。我每天都走路。然后当我确实开始重新骑自行车时，我骑得很慢，也非常小心。所以，你知道的，我想说的一点是，苏珊的反应是多么的正常和合理：记住与她姐姐经历的创伤，
and to see that replayed in her mind when she's looking at another person that she loves, to value the process of growth. And that might be a very slow, very step-by-step process. And then the last thing I want to say about that is that, you know, when we have the most terrible things happen to us, it can be very easy to have a kind of sort of purely deficit-based lens for understanding that experience, to understand it as essentially a disability, a limitation, a weakness in the self. And it's very healthy if you can ask the question, even if that was a difficult an experience and maybe causes me difficulty sometimes, maybe it makes me upset sometimes,
并在她看着另一个她所爱的人时，在脑海中重现那一幕，去重视成长的过程。这可能是一个非常缓慢、非常循序渐进的过程。然后我想对此说的最后一件事是，你知道的，当最可怕的事情发生在我们身上时，用一种纯粹基于缺陷的镜头来理解这段经历——基本上把它理解为一种残疾、一种局限、自身的一种软弱——会是非常容易的。如果你能提出这样的问题，那将是非常健康的：即使那是一段艰难的经历，有时可能会给我带来困难，有时可能会让我心烦意乱，
are there also strengths or goodnesses that come from that experience, maybe a sensitivity to others, an awareness of situations, and what the strength for Suzanne might be, what the strength for a different person might be, might be different things. But I think it's a very important question to ask ourselves to understand those strengths alongside the challenges that an experience like that poses. We received a note from a listener named Abby who called in about a time when she was an undergraduate in college. I was a biology major. I was thinking I wanted to maybe go into medicine, and I remember really struggling in organic chemistry. And it was rough. I was thinking I wasn't going to pass the course. And I remember going home for Thanksgiving break. And I was
这段经历是否也带来了力量或美好？也许是对他人的同理心、对局势的觉察。对于苏珊来说的力量可能是什么，对于另一个人来说的力量可能是什么，可能是不同的事情。但我认为这是一个非常重要的问题，我们需要问自己，以便在这样的经历带来的挑战之外，去理解这些力量。我们收到了听众艾比的一条留言，她谈到了她还在读大学本科时的一段经历。我当时是一名生物学专业学生。我当时在想我可能想从事医学，我记得我在有机化学这门课上真的很挣扎。而且过程很艰难。我当时觉得我这门课要挂科了。我记得感恩节假期回家了。我当时
talking with one of my uncles who I'm not particularly close with, but he's a surgeon, and I figured he knew what this was like. And I remember him starting to explain his experience, you know, with organic chemistry, going to an Ivy League school, finding it very hard in the class. He kind of turned it around and said, you know, but I dug in my heels and I just worked really hard. and I was failing at the midterm, but by the final, I got the highest score in the class on the final exam. And I remember just coming away from that conversation feeling kind of demoralized. I think I had already in my head anticipated the ending of the story as he was telling it.
正在和我的一个叔叔聊天，我和他并不是特别亲近，但他是一名外科医生，我想他应该知道这是怎么回事。我记得他开始解释他自己的经历，你知道的，关于有机化学，上常春藤盟校，发现这门课非常难。他话锋一转说道，你知道的，但我咬紧牙关，非常努力地工作。期中考试我考砸了，但到了期末考试，我考了全班期末考试的最高分。我记得从那次对话中走出来时，感觉备受打击。我想我在他讲述这个故事时，已经在脑海中预判了故事的结局。
He was going to tell me that, you know, I failed organic chemistry, but it's okay. I took it again, look how successful I am, it's okay. I guess my question is, why is it that sometimes we want a failure story to help us get over a struggle, and why is it that sometimes we want to hear about extraordinary people defying odds? I think this is a fascinating question, Greg. Sometimes when we're sad, all we want is to wallow in our sadness and listen to sad songs. Other times we desperately want hope and inspiration. From the point of view of trying to help someone else who is feeling down,
他会告诉我，你知道的，我有机化学挂科了，但没关系。我又修了一次，看我多成功，没关系。我想我的问题是，为什么有时我们想要一个失败的故事来帮助我们度过挣扎，而为什么有时我们想要听到关于不凡之人战胜逆境的故事呢？我认为这是一个迷人的问题，格雷格。有时当我们悲伤时，我们所想要的只是沉溺于悲伤中，听听伤感的歌曲。而其他时候，我们极度渴望希望和灵感。从试图帮助一个情绪低落的人的角度来看，
how do we know whether they need a mirror to reflect what they're feeling so we can tell them that they're not alone? And when do they need us to throw them a lifeline and pull them out of the water? Yeah, I think the best stories are actually both. That is, they are stories that connect with the real difficulty that people are. are having the depth of that challenge. And they're not stories of achievement of success. There are stories of process and growth. There's stories of how you build from darkness towards a trajectory that is right for you and right for how you want to become. And it sounds like with Abby's story that the conversation with her uncle turned into a story of triumph and success and achievement
我们怎么知道他们需要一面镜子来反映他们的感受，以便我们告诉他们他们并不孤单？以及什么时候他们需要我们向他们抛出救生索，把他们拉出水面？是的，我认为最好的故事实际上兼具这两者。也就是说，它们是与人们正在经历的真实困难、那种挑战的深度相连接的故事。它们不是关于成就或成功的叙事。它们是关于过程和成长的故事。它们讲述的是你如何从黑暗中建立起一条适合你、适合你想要成为的样子的轨迹。听起来，在艾比的故事中，她与叔叔的对话变成了一个关于胜利、成功和成就的故事，
more so than a story of growth. So there's work, for example, on role models, and what kind of role model stories are most effective for people. And the best kinds of role model stories are stories of growth over time, of change. They're not stories of success. It's not the success stories alone that are the best stories. It's the stories that are stories of change and growth.
而不是一个关于成长的故事。因此，例如，有一些关于榜样的研究，以及哪种榜样故事对人们最有效。而最好的榜样故事是关于随时间推移的成长、变化的故事。它们不是成功的故事。仅仅依靠成功故事并不是最好的故事。那些讲述变化和成长的故事才是最好的。
And for those stories to work, you have to really begin at that dark place, at that failure place. Maybe it's failing organic chemistry. We also received a story from a listener named Chris, who wanted to talk about some big changes in his life. About four years ago, Chris moved with his wife and two kids from the United States to Denmark.
为了让这些故事发挥作用，你必须真正从那个黑暗的地方、那个失败的地方开始。也许是挂了有机化学。我们还收到了听众克里斯的一条故事，他想谈谈他生活中的一些重大变化。大约四年前，克里斯和他的妻子以及两个孩子从美国搬到了丹麦。
My wife had a job opportunity, and we put our kids in Danish school, and they became fluent, and we really like living here. However, my job in the U.S., you know, the company was bought and I was laid off. And now I'm struggling mightily to build a new career here. I struggle with feelings of self-loathing. I can't give up because I know that the damage that would do to my family is worse than anything I would, you know, be relieving myself of. But I'm in the middle of it right now.
我妻子得到了一个工作机会，我们把孩子们送进了丹麦学校，他们变得能够流利使用丹麦语，我们真的很喜欢这里的生活。然而，我在美国的这份工作，你知道的，公司被收购了，我被裁员了。现在我在这里为了建立新的职业生涯而苦苦挣扎。我饱受自我厌恶情绪的困扰。我不能放弃，因为我知道那会对我的家庭造成的损害，比我你知道的想要借此解脱的任何事情都要糟糕。但我现在正深陷其中。
And as much as, you know, these stories of, you know, things are great and look how I turned it around, you know, I feel like I'm the person that your most recent podcast was geared towards. So Greg, I really hear the pain in Chris's voice here. He lost his job and now can't seem to find his way out of this professional downward spiral. What advice would you have for Chris? Yeah, I absolutely hear the pain in Chris's voice. And I hear also his commitment to his family. You know, I think the beginning of a process for Chris is just calling in like he's done, right? I think what's important is for him to be able to understand and articulate the experience that he's having, which he is doing.
尽管，你知道的，这些“事情很棒，看我是如何扭转局面的”故事，你知道的，我觉得我就是你最近这期播客所针对的那类人。所以格雷格，我真的能听到克里斯声音里的痛苦。他失去了工作，现在似乎找不到走出这个职业下行螺旋的方法。你对克里斯有什么建议吗？是的，我确实听到了克里斯声音里的痛苦。我也听到了他对家庭的承诺。你知道的，我认为克里斯开启这个过程的第一步就是像他现在这样打进电话来，对吧？我认为重要的是，他能够理解并表达他正在经历的体验，而他现在正在这样做。
And then to be able to having done that, start to think about what, what is. it is he wants to do with the time that he has in Denmark. There's an older intervention in psychology developed by Jamie Pennebaker called expressive writing interventions. And what this is, is really just taking the time to write about the deepest thoughts and feelings that you have, especially thoughts and feelings that aren't yet processed. And it's helpful because it helps people to tell stories of challenges that have a beginning, a middle, and an end, and to kind of stop that ruminative cycle that I could hear Chris worrying about, and that the caller at the beginning, Sherry, I think, was describing as well,
并且在做到这一点之后，开始思考他在丹麦拥有的这段时间里，他想要做些什么。心理学中有一个由杰米·佩尼贝克（Jamie Pennebaker）开发的较早的干预方法，称为表达性写作干预。这实际上就是花时间写下你内心的最深层的思想和感受，尤其是那些尚未被处理的思想和感受。这很有帮助，因为它能帮助人们讲述有头有尾、有中间过程的挑战故事，并能阻止那种我能听到克里斯在担忧的沉思循环，而且开头的那位来电者谢莉，我想她也描述过，
that kind of ruminative thought cycle. Because if you write it down, it's ridiculous to write something down like, I'm bad, I did something bad, I'm bad, I did something bad, I'm bad, I did something bad, I'm bad, I did something bad. Like, that's a boring. That's not going to work. So when you write it down, you can tell a story that has an end and kind of put a pin on it. And then once you've put a pin on it, you can start to do the second part of the work
那种反刍式的思维循环。因为如果你把它写下来，写下诸如“我很糟糕，我做了一件坏事，我很糟糕，我做了一件坏事，我很糟糕，我做了一件坏事，我很糟糕，我做了一件坏事”这样的话是很荒谬的。就像，那太无聊了。那样是行不通的。所以当你把它写下来时，你可以讲述一个有结局的故事，并在上面做个标记。一旦你在上面做了标记，你就可以开始做第二部分的工作了，
and to think about what you want to do with the time that you have in the circumstance that you're in, what would be of meaning to you, what would be of value to you. But you kind of have to do that first work first. You've sometimes said that the focus of your work is about this idea of becoming. Can you unpack that idea for me, Greg? Yeah. What we do is we think about where we are and where it is that we want to go, who you want to become, what you want to do with the circumstance that you're in, given whatever that
并思考在你所处的环境中，在你拥有的这段时间里，你想做些什么，什么对你而言是有意义的，什么对你而言是有价值的。但你必须先完成第一部分的工作。你有时曾说过，你工作的焦点是关于“成为”这个概念。你能为我剖析一下这个概念吗，格雷格？是的。我们所做的是，思考我们现在在哪里，以及我们想要去哪里，你想要成为谁，在鉴于你所处的任何环境的情况下，你想要用这段环境做些什么，无论那是什么。
circumstance is. And part of that involves your identity, you know, what's valuable to you, what's important to you, the things that matter most. to you, and that informs the kind of goals that you have, the aspirations you have, to do this or to be in this space, or to explore that, to climb this mountain, whatever it might be. It might involve the communities that you want to join. I think that's why belonging in school is so important, because school is a vehicle for becoming. Like school is how we become the people that we want to become.
这其中一部分涉及你的身份，你知道的，什么对你是有价值的，什么对你重要，那些最重要的事情，而这决定了你拥有的目标、你的抱负——去做到这一点，或者在这个空间里存在，或者去探索那个，去攀登这座山，无论它可能是什么。它可能涉及你想要加入的社群。我认为这就是为什么在学校里的归属感如此重要，因为学校是“成为”的载体。就像学校是我们如何成为我们想成为的人的方式。
It's our opportunity to build skills and build relationships that help us get to. the kind of person that we want to become. And the barriers that come up along the way, the psychological barriers, things like fixed mindsets of intelligence, like if you take that organic chemistry class and you see that as the vehicle to become the doctor you want to be and you fail that organic chemistry class and you think that means I'm dumb at organic chemistry, that means I can't be a doctor. That's a threat to your becoming. Or questions like, I don't belong here. People don't value me here. I'm not contributing here. That's a threat. you're becoming within that space.
这是我们建立技能和建立关系的机会，这些技能和关系有助于我们成为我们想成为的那种人。而这一路上出现的障碍，心理障碍，比如关于智力的固定思维模式——如果你上了那门有机化学课，并将其视为成为你想成为的医生的载体，而你那门有机化学课挂了，你认为这意味着我在有机化学方面很笨，这意味着我不能当医生。这对你的“成为”构成了威胁。或者诸如“我不属于这里。这里的人不重视我。我没有在这里做出贡献”之类的问题。这对你的“成为”构成了威胁。
And really what I'm hearing you say then is that when we experience these spirals, what we're really experiencing are threats to our hopes and our dreams of the kind of people that we could become. That's where the fear and the anxiety, that's where it comes from. Exactly. I shared earlier that I had had the opportunity to do some events with alum this past fall, and I want to just tell one story from that. I had asked a group of alum in Orange County to talk about a time when somebody saw in them the good and successful person that they could become, maybe even when they weren't there yet.
那我听到你所说的是，当我们经历这些恶性循环时，我们真正经历的其实是对我们的希望和梦想的威胁——关于我们可以成为什么样的的那种人的梦想。恐惧和焦虑就是从那里产生的。完全正确。我早些时候分享过，去年秋天我有机会与校友们一起参加了一些活动，我想讲其中的一个故事。我曾请奥兰治县的一群校友谈谈这样一个时刻：当时有人在他们身上看到了他们可以成为的那个善良且成功的人，也许甚至在他们当时还没达到那个状态时。
And one of the people there, he told a story. He started work at a company. He long admired, a company he greatly respected, a company he was proud to be at, but he felt he was floundering. He didn't feel he understood his job well. He thought he was not doing well. He was worried he might get laid off. He was in the probationary. period. And the company was, his office was in Orange County, but the company had a headquarters on the East Coast, and the boss of his boss came in one day from the East Coast. And so his boss and his boss of his boss are standing near his desk talking, but not to him. And then his boss comes to his desk and puts his hand on his shoulder. And he says, this is going to be one of our stars. This is going to be one of our people. And the boss, boss, boss, then introduces himself and shows the person a great deal of respect.
其中在那里的一个人讲了一个故事。他开始在一家公司工作。那是一家他长期仰慕的公司，一家他深为敬佩的公司，一家他为之自豪的公司，但他觉得自己在艰难摸索。他觉得自已对工作不够了解。他认为自己做得不好。他担心自己可能会被裁员。他正处于试用期。这家公司的办公室在奥兰治县，但公司总部在东海岸，他老板的老板有一天从东海岸过来了。所以他的老板和老板的老板正站在他的办公桌旁聊天，但不是在跟他聊天。然后他的老板来到他的办公桌前，把手放在他的肩膀上。他说，这将是我们的明星员工之一。这将是我们的核心人才之一。而老板的老板的老板随后作了自我介绍，并对这个人表现出极大的尊重。
And he told this story and he said that that was the moment that he realized that he could become the kind of worker at this company that he wanted to become. And that was the ordinary magic for him. When we come back, listeners share their advice on how to get out of a spiral. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedan. At Stanford University, Greg Walton studies how we end up in downward spirals.
他讲述了这个故事，并说那一刻他意识到，他可以在这家公司成为他想要成为的那种员工。这就是对他而言的普通魔法。稍后回来，听众们将分享他们关于如何摆脱恶性循环的建议。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在斯坦福大学，格雷格·沃尔顿研究我们是如何陷入下行螺旋的。
He's the author of Ordinary Magic, the science of how we can achieve big change with small acts. Today, he's responding to listener questions and comments in our latest segment of your questions answered. One of the tricky parts of confronting bad news is that we tend to ask ourselves, what does this mean for my future? These worries can overwhelm us and lead to a lot of anxiety. A listener named Carolyn called in with her experience. I lost my job at the right age of 66 and was basically thrown into retirement. I don't know how people manage, but step by step, I signed up for Medicare and all the other Social Security stuff, looked for a part-time job, found a new place to live.
他是《普通魔法：小行动如何成就大改变的科学》一书的作者。今天，他正在我们的最新栏目“您的提问已解答”中回应听众的问题和评论。面对坏事时棘手的部分之一是，我们倾向于问自己：这对我的未来意味着什么？这些担忧会压垮我们，并导致大量的焦虑。一位名叫卡洛琳的听众打来电话，分享了她的经历。我在66岁正好的年纪失去了工作，基本上被推向了退休。我不知道人们是如何应对的，但一步接一步，我注册了医疗保险和所有其他的社会安全福利，寻找兼职工作，找到了新的住处。
It was pretty tumultuous, but I had to just keep putting one foot in front of the other. That's the only way you can survive. So Carolyn tried to take things step by step, Greg, solve one problem at a time. I actually think that this is psychologically very wise. Instead of getting overwhelmed by the big picture, she focused just on one step that was right in front of her. What do you think of this approach? Yeah, absolutely. So there's, we call this proximal.
过程相当混乱，但我不得不一直保持着前脚紧跟后脚的步伐。这是你能生存下去的唯一方法。所以卡洛琳试着一步一步来，格雷格，一次解决一个问题。我实际上认为这在心理学上是非常明智的。她没有被大局压倒，而是只专注于眼前的那一步。你觉得这种方法怎么样？是的，绝对如此。所以我们把这称之为“近端目标”。
goals. And this was an idea that was researched in the 80s by my colleague Al Bandura, studying originally kids who were really struggling in math. So these were elementary school kids were way behind in math. And in one of the studies that he did, he gave kids a bunch of math worksheets. And in one condition, he said, do as many as you can. And in the other condition, he said, do six pages per day. And it's the same thing. But the six pages per day breaks it down and says, here's what my goal is. I'm going to do six pages per day. And that increased kids' confidence in their ability to do math, and it increased their performance in math. And the psychology of it is really that when you break it down into manageable bits and you work on each bit and you accomplish
这是我同事阿尔·班杜拉（Al Bandura）在80年代研究的一个概念，最初研究的是在数学上苦苦挣扎的孩子们。所以这些是数学远远落后的小学生。在他进行的一项研究中，他给孩子们发了一堆数学练习纸。在一个条件下，他说，能做多少就做多少。而在另一个条件下，他说，每天做六页。其实是一回事。但“每天做六页”把它分解了，并说：这就是我的目标。我打算每天做六页。这增强了孩子们做数学题能力的信心，并提高了他们的数学表现。其背后的心理学原理其实是，当你把它分解成可管理的碎片，并且你处理好每一个碎片并完成了每一个碎片，你会感觉稍微好一点，你会感到更有自信，你会感觉到一点点进展，然后在一天结束时，你可能就已经登上了山顶。
each bit, you feel a little bit better, you feel a little bit more confident, you feel a little bit of progress, and that at the end of the day, then you maybe have climbed the mountain top. A listener named Estelle called in with her experience of a downward spiral and how she got out of it. The year 2012 was special because a lot of really crappy things happened. I had relationship, instability, and lost three jobs. So how did I get out of this? I sent A somewhat simple question for myself, I said in six months from now, I just started a new job. In six months, I'm going to ask myself honestly, do I love it here? Is this where I want to be?
一位名叫埃斯特尔的听众打来电话，分享了她陷入恶性循环以及她如何摆脱它的经历。2012年是很特殊的一年，因为发生了很多真的很烂的事情。我的感情不稳定，还失去了三份工作。那么我是如何摆脱这一切的呢？我问了自己一个相对简单的问题，我说从现在起六个月后，我刚刚开始了一份新工作。在六个月后，我要诚实地问自己：我喜欢这里吗？这是我想待的地方吗？
And six months go by, and I didn't lose that job. But when I asked myself honestly at the six-month checkpoint, is this how I want to feel? The answer was no. I didn't enjoy what I was doing. I didn't want to keep doing what I was doing for the rest of my life. I started figuring out what my exit plan was going to be, and I decided I was going to go back to school, and I was going to completely change my career. I still use this strategy now.
六个月过去了，我没有失去那份工作。但是当我真诚地在六个月的检查点问自己：这是我想有的感受吗？答案是否定的。我不喜欢我正在做的事情。我不想在余生里继续做我正在做的事。我开始琢磨我的退路会是什么，我决定重返校园，并且我打算彻底改变我的职业生涯。直到现在我仍然在使用这个策略。
I set checkpoints for myself, and I give myself reasonable metrics that I can keep track of, and check in with myself at some later point and see if something is still working for me or if it's not. And if it's not, then I can change it. So, Greg, one thing I love about Estelle's strategy is that she sets a point where she checks a point where she checks, with herself about a decision. And that means she no longer has to think about the decision every day. She doesn't have to constantly ask herself, am I happy, am I unhappy? Is this job going to turn out like all the others? By having these predefined checkpoints, in some ways, she takes the pressure off the daily questions that can lead to negative spirals. Yeah, I love it. It reminds me a
我为自己设定检查点，并给自己设定我可以追踪的合理指标，在之后的某个时间点自我检查一下，看看某件事情是否仍然对我有用，还是已经失效了。如果失效了，那么我就可以改变它。所以，格雷格，我喜欢埃斯特尔的策略的一点是，她设定了一个时间点，用来就某个决定对自己进行检查。这意味着她不再需要每天都去思考这个决定。她不必不断地问自己：我快乐吗？我不快乐吗？这工作会变得和以前的其他工作一样吗？通过设立这些预定义的检查点，在某种程度上，她减轻了每日那些可能导致消极循环的提问所带来的压力。是的，我喜欢这个。这让我想起了，
little bit of the kind of unhelpfulness of the question, what do you want to be when you grow up? It's just like too big of a question, like my whole life. Like I always think it's much more useful. Like when I'm talking with undergraduates, for example, to ask a question like, what do you want to do for a couple years? You know, what would you like to try out? And then as exactly as Estelle is saying, check in with yourself. How do you like that?
“你长大后想做什么？”这个问题其实并没有太大帮助。这就好像问题太大了，比如我的整个人生。我总是认为这要实用得多。例如，当我与本科生交谈时，我会问这样一个问题：你头几年想做什么？你知道的，你想尝试什么？然后就像埃斯特尔所说的那样，自我检查一下。你喜欢那个吗？
Is that working for you? Are you seeing the paths of growth that are inspiring for you? And are you becoming the kind of person that you want to be or maybe not? And so sort of breaking it down into manageable bits and then checking in with yourself as those manageable bits come up, it's very helpful. And to the extent that our worries are prompted again by our concerns that we're not becoming the people we want to be, as you said, you know, there's a tendency to want to worry about those questions all the time. And what I like about what Estelle is doing is she's basically saying those are important questions. I'm going to get to them, but that doesn't mean I have to think about them all the time. Right. So if you're asking the question, like, do I want to be an X at every single day that you're trying to do the X?
那对你有用吗？你看到了那些能激励你成长的道路吗？你正在成为你想成为的那种人吗，还是说并没有？因此，将其分解为可管理的碎片，然后在这些可管理的碎片出现时自我检查，这非常有帮助。并且在我们的担忧再次由我们的担忧所引发——担心我们没有成为我们想成为的人——正如你所说的那样，你知道的，人们往往倾向于一直担心这些问题。而我喜欢埃斯特尔所做的是，她基本上是在说这些都是重要的问题。我会去解决它们的，但这并不意味着我必须一直想着它们。没错。所以如果你在问这个问题，比如，我在尝试做X的每一天都在问“我想成为一名X吗？”
Like, you're not actually doing the X. You're not actually interacting with the people in that work environment. You're not trying to build the skills of that environment. You're not joshing around with the people or going to happy hours or experiencing that space the way that it would be in that space. You're distracted the whole time by the meta question. We received a question from a listener named Mark who realized that he needed the help of others to escape his downward spiral. After my wife died in April 2025, I went through a very deep downward spiral. I thought my life was over and I thought I could never be happy again. What I realized was I needed to use people who love me to help me get out of this spiral. I went to the East Coast for 14 days and saw friends. I went to China for a month where my daughter and granddaughter live with their wonderful family.
就像，你其实并没有在做X。你并没有真正与那个工作环境中的人互动。你没有试图培养那个环境中的技能。你没有和大家开玩笑，也没有去欢乐时光，或者以那种环境应有的方式去体验那个空间。你一直被这个元问题分心了。我们收到了听众马克的一条提问，他意识到他需要他人的帮助才能摆脱下行螺旋。在我妻子于2025年4月去世后，我经历了一次非常深的下行螺旋。我以为我的人生结束了，我觉得我再也不可能快乐了。我意识到的是，我需要借助那些爱我的人来帮助我摆脱这个螺旋。我去东海岸待了14天，见了一些朋友。我去中国待了一个月，我的女儿和孙女以及他们美妙的家人就住在那里。
When I came back, I was ready to start life again. I shed most of my addictive behaviors and met a woman soon after that who helped me go on this upward spiral. She exercises every day, eats healthy, and has lots of fun. just what I needed after this difficult experience. Greg, what role do other people in our life play when it comes to dealing with a downward spiral? Yeah, I mean, they're essential. We are a social animal, and we do not do any of this work by ourselves. We always do it with other people. Mark's story is a beautiful story, a beautiful story of self-insight and of leaning on others, and of, you know, when you're in a very dark space, like if you've lost a spouse, for example,
当我回来时，我已经准备好重新开始生活了。我摆脱了大部分令人上瘾的行为，并在那之后不久遇到了一位女性，她帮助我进入了这个上行螺旋。她每天锻炼，饮食健康，充满乐趣。这正是我经历这段艰难时期后所需要的。格雷格，在应对下行螺旋时，我们生命中的其他人扮演了什么角色？是的，我的意思是，他们是至关重要的。我们是社会性动物，我们绝不可能独自完成所有这些工作。我们总是与其他人一起完成。马克的故事是一个美丽的故事，一个关于自我洞察、依靠他人、以及当你处于一个非常黑暗的空间时——比如如果你失去了配偶，
who you love very much, and I could hear that in Mark's voice, the world can seem very dark. And then if you can interact with people who aren't in that headspace and people who care about you and people who can share with you other ways of view in the world, opportunities, things that are of interest, those opportunities and things that are of interest can come into your way of seen as well. And I think that that's part of the story that Mark is telling us there. And it's a lesson for all of us. Speaking of loved ones, Greg, let's end where we started with the experience of Sherry. I told you as a young woman she considered suicide because of her negative spirals.
你非常深爱的人，我在马克的嗓音中听到了这一点——世界可能显得非常黑暗。然后，如果你能与那些不在那种精神状态中、关心你并且能与你分享其他看世界的方式、机会、你感兴趣的事物的人互动，那些机会和感兴趣的事物也可以进入你的视野中。我认为这就是马克在那儿告诉我们的故事的一部分。这对我们所有人来说都是一个教训。说到挚爱之人，格雷格，让我们以谢莉的经历作为我们开始的地方结束吧。我告诉过你，作为一个年轻女性，她曾因为消极的恶性循环而考虑过自杀。
I let her pick up the story from here. these kinds of terrible looping thoughts that at some point had me thinking about suicide quite a bit because I just didn't think that there was a way out of all of that. Something dropped into me one day to make a list of reasons why I loved my mom. And when I started to make this list of reasons why I loved my mother, I realized maybe not quite right at that exact moment, but down the road, I realized looking back that when I was immersed in thinking about why I love someone, that those other looping negative spiraling voices didn't have space. They weren't there. This became a lifelong practice for me. This was 30-some
我让她从这里开始继续讲述她的故事。这些可怕的循环往复的想法在某个时刻让我考虑了相当多的自杀，因为我只是觉得所有这些都没有出路。有一天，某种领悟降临在我身上，让我列出一份我爱我妈妈的理由的清单。当我开始列出这些爱我母亲的理由时，我意识到，也许不是在那确切的时刻，而是在之后的某个时间，我回过头来意识到，当我沉浸在思考我为什么爱一个人时，那些其他循环往复的消极恶性循环的声音就没有空间了。它们不在那里。这成为了我一生的习惯。这是30多
years ago that I made that very first list. I now, I call them love lists, and it's a tool that I as a combination of a gratitude tool, a personal development tool, a meditation tool, and it's a gift. A gift we can give to someone else that I think will help them with their own spiraling, looping negative thoughts because now they have a list of beautiful things about themselves. Greg, what do you make of Sherry's idea of love lists? Can gratitude help us get out of these negative spirals? Yeah, I mean, Sherry, what a beautiful. story and what a beautiful, wise intervention. You know, I think there's nothing more important for us than other people and the relationships that we have, the real, authentic, close relationships where
年前我列下了第一份那样的清单。我现在，我称它们为“爱之清单”，它是一个工具，我将其作为感恩工具、个人发展工具、冥想工具的结合体，这是一个礼物。一份我们可以送给别人的礼物，我认为这会帮助他们应对他们自己的循环往复的消极思维，因为现在他们手里有了一份关于他们自身的充满美好事物的清单。格雷格，你怎么看谢莉的“爱之清单”这个主意？感恩能帮助我们摆脱这些消极的恶性循环吗？是的，我的意思是，谢莉，这是一个多么美丽的故事，多么美丽、充满智慧的干预。你知道的，我认为没有什么比其他人以及我们拥有的关系更重要的了，那些真实、真诚、亲密的、
you're seen and you're valued. And when you can get back in contact with that, the negativity can just fall away, as you describe in your experience. It's beautiful, and thank you for sharing that. I'm wondering, Greg, whether this is something that you do as well. How do you get yourself out of negative spirals? Yeah, I mean, I think definitely the kind of, you know, 3 a.m. anxiety experience, like anxiety peaks, you know, early in the morning. You can't sleep, you wake up. I think one thing that helps is to just write down the things that you're anxious about, right? So you, that's something I've definitely done. I think another thing that helps me is just the kind of meta-awareness that this is, it's almost a mindfulness, is that this is a thought, this is a time of anxiety, and things will look a little bit different at a different time, maybe from a different perspective, maybe just at 10 in the morning
你能被看见、被珍视的关系。而当你能重新与它建立联系时，负面情绪就会自然消散，正如你在你的经历场所描述的那样。这很美妙，感谢你分享这个。我想知道，格雷格，这也是你所做的事情吗？你是如何让自己摆脱消极的恶性循环的？是的，我的意思是，我认为绝对有那种，你知道的，凌晨3点的焦虑体验，比如焦虑高峰，你知道的，在清晨。你睡不着，你醒了。我认为有帮助的一件事就是简单地写下让你焦虑的事情，对吧？所以，这是我绝对做过的事情。我认为另一件对我有帮助的事情是那种元觉察——这几乎是一种正念——即这只是一种想法，这是一个焦虑的时刻，事情在不同的时间、从不同的视角、也许仅仅是在早上10点，
in light of a conversation with somebody I care about or somebody who cares about me. So that meta-awareness is also helpful. and I think that the surfacing is really important to be able to say what it is and then to kind of diagnose it. Like, where is it that that is coming from? Why is it that I'm having this anxiety at this time? There's a reason for that. I might not know the reason for that, but there's a reason for that. And if I could figure out that reason, it's almost like understanding the root cause.
在与我关心的人或关心我的人对话的启发下，看起来会有所不同。所以这种元觉察也是很有帮助的。而且我认为浮现出来真的很重要，能够说出它是什么，然后去诊断它。就像，那到底是从哪里来的？为什么我在这个时候会有这种焦虑？这是有原因的。我可能不知道原因，但这是有原因的。如果我能弄清楚那个原因，那就几乎像是理解了根本原因。
And then I can actually work on the thing that actually matters, not the kithbit manifestation of it. Greg Walton is a psychologist at Stanford University. He is the author of Ordinary Magic, the science of how we can achieve big change with small acts. Greg, thank you so much for joining me again today on Hidden Brain. Thank you very much. It's been a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul,
然后我实际上可以致力于解决真正重要的事情，而不是它的信息碎片表现形式。格雷格·沃尔顿是斯坦福大学的心理学家。他是《普通魔法：小行动如何成就大改变的科学》一书的作者。格雷格，非常感谢你今天再次做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。这真是个荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔、
Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. If you enjoyed today's conversation, please consider sharing it with your friends. Put out word of it on social media or your office Slack channel. I'm Shankar Vedantham.
克里斯汀·王、劳拉·克雷尔、莱恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢今天的对话，请考虑与你的朋友分享。在社交媒体或你办公室的Slack频道上宣传它。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。